vraiment qui nous sommes
les valeurs que nous défendons la
liberté
la liberté d'expression et d'opinion
nous défendons l'égalité l'égalité des
chances pour tous
[Musique]
nous sommes une équipe
nous sommes cette diversité qui fait la
france
et nous en sommes fiers
[Musique]
et si vous veniez voir par vous même
bonsoir à tous bienvenue sur rt france
pour deux heures d'émission nous
décrypterons comme chaque soir du lundi
au jeudi l'essentiel de l'information
avec nous inviter toujours tenus à bonne
distance et nos reporters l'actualité
toujours dominée par les crises du
coronavirus en france et dans le monde
voici les titres
le second tour des municipales aura lieu
aura-t-il lieu fin juin c'était l'objet
du conseil des ministres aujourd'hui
hier le conseil scientifique a donné un
prudent feu vert et edouard philippe
doit rencontrer ce soir les responsables
de partis le ministre de la santé lui
s'est engagé pour un renouveau de
l'hôpital public
comment faire repartir l'économie
française en souffrance après cette
crise
pour bruno le maire la relance
économique doit être verte respectueuse
de l'environnement et l'idée n'est pas
de faire travailler plus les français
mais que tous les français doivent
travailler mais la question du temps de
travail nourrit toujours les débats
alors faut-il travailler plus pour
sauver l'économie française ce sera
l'objet de notre face à face à 20h15
en europe la suède a suivi sa propre
stratégie celle du nom confinement et de
l'immunité collective
si les autres pays lève peu à peu les
mesures de restriction les suédois eux
envisagent de les maintenir plus
longtemps côté italien les aéroports
pourront rouvrir à partir du 3 juin
outre-atlantique le canada se prépare à
retrouver une liberté de circulation ce
lundi 25 mai mais l'inquiétude demeure
car la belle province concentre plus de
2200 décès
[Musique]
un conseil des ministres s'est donc
tenue ce matin au programme
l'organisation du déconfinement bien sûr
mais aussi le second tour des élections
municipales le conseil scientifique a
donné son accord pour le mois de juin à
condition de réévaluer la situation
quinze jours avant edouard philippe
s'est entretenu dans la journée avec les
chefs des partis à ce sujet pour en
parler nous sommes en direct avec moi
qui me croyais au député ps de la
première circonscription de l'orne
candidat à la mairie d'alençon bonsoir
les eaux qui me paye au merci d'être
avec nous en direct sur rt france alors
vous vous êtes arrivé en tête du premier
tour à alençon et vous souhaitez un
second tour en juin
je rajouterais peut-être logiquement
c'est souvent le cas de ce qu'ils soient
en ballottage favorable
oui je sais pas si c'est logique mais si
vous voulez je pense de la mesure où le
gouvernement a validé le premier tour
des élections municipales pour les
listes qui ont été directement élus et
donc il reste effectivement cette
séquence du deuxième tour nous sommes
dans un déconfinement progressif si le
déconfinement se passe dans des bonnes
conditions
je pense que les élections municipales
peuvent se dérouler sous réserve bien
évidemment que les conditions sanitaires
soient réservées et que les
recommandations de comités scientifiques
soient respectées à la lettre
vous savez une campagne du 2ème qu'au
deuxième tour c'est en temps normal
c'est une campagne courte elle dure une
semaine et donc si ledit confinement se
déroulent dans des bonnes conditions je
crois qu'il faut reprendre le chemin
d'un démocratie parce que les
collectivités jouent un rôle important
dans le développement économique dans le
lien social dans la protection
d'environnement et je pense qu'il serait
logique que ce soient les équipes qui
vont être élus
au deuxième tour qui doivent mener ces
politiques publiques
je crois que c'est important de le dire
je suis au parti socialiste et d'où nous
avons effectivement débattu de ce sujet
là nous sommes d'accord pour dire au
premier ministre
ok pour le 28 juin sous réserve bien
évidemment que les conditions sanitaires
soient réunies et que quinze jours avant
le comité scientifique donne à nouveau
son feu vert
et dans ces conditions il n'y a aucune
raison pour que les élections n'aient
pas lieu de la mesure où on demande aux
français de travailler on a ouvert les
écoles les collèges
on va peut-être ouvrir les lieux de
restauration des lieux touristiques
courant juin donc on peut effectivement
ouvrir dans ces conditions les bureaux
de vote si on peut pas ça veut dire
qu'effectivement le déconfinement aurait
échoué
eliaquim voyons vous le savez quoi qu'on
en dise il y a eu des gens malades lors
du premier tour que cela soit pendant la
campagne ou pendant le vote
en ce jour du 15 mars lorsque vous
n'avez pas peur qu'on reproduise
justement les mêmes erreurs beaucoup on
parlait même de faute grave de la part
du gouvernement de maintenir ce premier
tour
écoutez je pense que si gouvernement
hésite
iliad il ya bien des raisons
actuellement il ya une concertation qui
est fait avec les associations des
maires je pense aux maires de france
quitte une très grosse association la mf
le président a rappelé les mêmes
arguments que je viens de vous dire
et puis vous avez l'association
également france urbaine qui regroupe
les grosses métropoles les communistes
urbaine qui partagent la même analyse
parce que tant qu'on n'a pas de vaccin
il faudra vivre avec le co vide et on
sait pas où on en sera au mois de
septembre ou à l'automne parce que si on
repartait en septembre en octobre
est ce qu'on sera débarrassés du gobi ne
suis pas certain donc si le
déconfinement se passe plutôt bien
s'il n'y a pas de deuxième vague
si les conditions sanitaires sont
respectées je pense que on peut aller
voter comme on peut aller effectivement
dans d'autres lieux qui seront ouvert
courant juin donc voila c c'est une
c'est une hypothèse que qui est forte et
je sais pas quelle sera la décision
semblerait qu'on s'oriente vers une
élection municipale fin juin je pense
qu'on peut faire confiance à aux
pouvoirs publics pour que ces élections
se déroulent dans de bonnes conditions
voilà si effectivement en reportant
septembre j'en prendrais hâte mais on ne
sera pas sûr également qu'on septembre
on est également des conditions plus
favorables ce qu'on va trouver fin juin
donc c'est une question la démocratie la
démocratie doit pas être du côté je
pense que si od confine l'ensemble des
secteurs d'activité eh bien il faut que
la démocratie se dé confine également
avec les conditions que je vous ai
rappelé parce qu'effectivement ces
quinze jours avant le premier tour
on s'aperçoit qu'il ya une deuxième
pandémie qui arrivent là je peux
comprendre également qu'il faut stopper
le processus électoral justement eu
hakim foyot vous parlez de démocratie
richard ferrand hier le président de
l'assemblée parlé également de
démocratie est justement mettez en garde
contre un déni de démocratie
il évoque lui le fait de ne pas pouvoir
mener campagne sur le terrain vous savez
bien vous même je vais pas me la prendre
qu'une campagne c'est elle est au
contact de la population expliquer son
programme etc
vous comprenez quand même ces craintes
quelle est votre réponse oui on peut
comprendre ces craintes mais si vous
voulez nous sommes dans une période
inédite exceptionnel quand vous demandez
aux ouvriers d'aller travailler dans
leurs usines
il ya effectivement des conditions
sanitaires qui sont mises en place et
c'est plus du tout la même chose
qu'avant le coc vide quand vous demandez
à des collégiens ou à des écoliers
d'aller à l'école
il ya des conditions effectivement
d'enseignement qui sont différentes de
ce qu'on a pu vivre avant le coc vide
quand on va ouvrir
les restaurants pour permettre à cette
filière de reprendre effectivement leur
activité on va demander aux
consommateurs est également aux
responsables des restaurants de mettre
en place des conditions sera pas la même
chose qu auparavant
alors on peut également continué le
raisonnement par rapport aux élections
vous savez une campagne de deuxième tour
c'est une campagne très courte qui dure
une semaine en temps normal
effectivement il ya une ou deux réunions
il ya des distributions de tracts
je pense que les les les électeurs ont
vécu premier tour donc il connaît ses
candidats ils connaissent les listes
connaissent les programmes qui pourront
être adaptées en fonction du coc vide ou
repositionner en sur tel point par
rapport à telle autre
mais si on ne le fait pas maintenant si
on le reporte au mois de septembre
il faut qu'on soit certain qu'au mois de
septembre on est plutôt vide et là on en
n'est pas du tout certain
donc je crois que c'est vrai que c'est
difficile je peux comprendre ceux qui
hésitent mais je peux comprendre
également les élus et nous avons deux
grosses associations en france la mf et
france urbaine qui ont écrit une lettre
au premier ministre pour demander en
toute responsabilité
la tenue de ces élections mais bien
évidemment c'est le comité scientifique
qui devra donner le feu vert
quinze jours avant et puis ensuite les
collectivités et bien mettront en place
tout protocoles nécessaires pour que les
électeurs puissent voter dans des bonnes
conditions
voilà donc j mais également des réserves
en fonction du de la pic de l'épidémie
si cette pandémie est en décroissance je
pense qu'on pourra effectivement tenir
ces élections si au contraire on a
effectivement une épidémie qui reprend
force dans une dizaine de jours ou dans
une quinzaine de jours là effectivement
je peux comprendre que le gouvernement
fera une proposition
ma dernière question est un crime soyons
rapidement est ce que vous ne craignez
pas ce qu'on appelle un scrutin
insincère beaucoup d'élus l'on dénonçait
déjà
oui mais ça on l'avait
certains l'ont dénoncé au premier tour
alors comment vous allez compte expliqué
même juridiquement ça peut poser un
problème
vous avez dans les petites communes des
élus qui ont été lues directement
première premier tour mais tous les élus
n'ont pas été élus parce qu'il ya du
panachage donc on l'a on attend encore
le deuxième tour la commune est bloqué
parce que si effectivement on a décidé
d'installer tous les élus qui ont été
élus directement premier tour vous avez
des communes où il ya des délices de
panassac n'est pas des listes complètes
donc il ya un problème juridique et est
ce que on peut en france dire voilà il
ya des communes qui le premier tour a
été validé pour telle commune et puis
par contre pour les autres communes
c'est pas sincère veut dire qu'à un
moment donné je veux dire que le taux
d'abstention il est quasiment semblables
avec des disparités pour tous les
départements y compris pour les élus qui
ont été élus au premier tour
y compris pour les élus qui sont en
ballottage donc c'est un sujet
effectivement de l'abstention qui a été
marquée par le cos vide
et si effectivement le déconfinement se
passe dans des bonnes conditions s'il ya
de la confiance qui se met en place
entre les habitants et également les
pouvoirs publics et les pouvoirs
économiques si effectivement on nous
démontre que la courbe est vraiment
descendante
la confiance va revenir et je pense que
les électeurs reprendront le chemin des
hommes parce que c'est la démocratie est
très importante voilà donc merci moi j'y
mets des conditions mais j'explique que
si effectivement les conditions sont
réunies et bien haut pour a on a gagné
ces élections du 2e tour merci à vous
d'avoir été en direct comment était géré
la crise sanitaire en france pour tenter
d'y répondre la france insoumise a mis
en place une sorte de commission
denquête les résultats sont tombés des
parlementaires il dénonce je cite un
fiasco du pouvoir face aux coronavirus
et pointe du doigt des erreurs et des
mensonges notamment concernant les
masques et les tests pour eric coquerel
députés et les filles de
seine-saint-denis ce rapport révèle que
la crise du comité 19 a mis la lumière
et sur les difficultés du système prôné
par le gouvernement en tire confirme nos
impressions c'est à dire qu'il ya eu à
la fois des erreurs
erin de commises des morceaux et puis
globalement à ce système qui est vide et
au libéralisme
qu'ils aillent dire avec est en crise
parce que c'est lui qui a transformé une
crise épidémique entrée sanitaires et
crise sociale la force de baisser les
dépenses publiques apport de blessés
d'attaquer la santé publique
à force de délocaliser de les priver de
toute souveraineté sanitaires etc etc
c'est l'expérience et le constat que
nous faisons le bilan que nous faisons
dans sur youtube et alors que des
députés de la france insoumise remettent
en cause le modèle néolibéral la crise
sanitaire s'apprête à laisser place à la
crise économique nous allons souffrir
sur le front de l'emploi prévient
emmanuel macron le pib a déjà plongé de
6% au premier trimestre 2001 la france
est entrée en récession alors question
faut-il travailler plus pour sauver
l'économie de notre pays c'est l'objet
de notre face à face ce soir
[Musique]
et pour en débattre nous sommes en
direct avec benjamin hama membres du
bureau confédéral de la cgt
benjamin marquis est un cadre un du
syndicat bonsoir à vous philippe herlin
ses côtés pour en débattre économistes
vous êtes l'auteur de plusieurs ouvrages
dont pouvoir d'achat le grand mensonge
aux éditions eyrolles
bonsoir également avoue philippe herlin
alors c'est un pavé dans la mare lancé
par le patron du medef le 11 avril
dernier je rappelle les termes il faudra
travailler un peu plus afin de relancer
l'économie
à mois plus tard nous avons donc entamé
un vous le savez je vous le rappelle pas
le déconfinement avec la crise
économique qui nous guette cette
déclaration je froid de geoffroy roux de
bézieux est-ce qu'elle était
prémonitoire
selon vous philippe herlin il va falloir
travailler plus il faut travailler plus
mais pas seulement il faut aussi que il
sera plus intéressant de travailler en
france c'est à dire qu'il faut diminuer
leur charge fiscale qui pèse sur les
entreprises
il faut bien comprendre que le
coronavirus c'est pas la cause de la
crise avant le coronavirus la france
allait déjà mal y avait du chômage y
avait des failles et d'entreprises les
choses il y avait une très faible
croissance et donc il faut le
coronavirus a joué un rôle de
déclencheur en quelque sorte mais si ça
n'avait pas été le corps n'avait russie
aurait eu un autre choc externe qui
aurait pu déstabiliser l'économie de la
même façon donc il faut moi je suis
convaincu il faut s'attacher aux
problèmes structurels de l'économie
française donc un niveau d'impôts trop
élevé je rappelle que le taux de
prélèvements obligatoires en france est
le plus élevé des pays de l' ocde
il ya aussi la complexité fiscale
c'est extrêmement complexe et c'est
d'autant plus complexe pour les pme les
grands groupes qui peuvent se payer des
fiscalistes mais les pme les tpe ils
peuvent pas et c'est une prise de tête
incroyable
il ya aussi le changement régulier des
impôts qui fait tout cette variabilité
cette volatilité de l'impôt est aussi
complexe
voilà il ya aussi un code du travail qui
est bien trop complexe et donc il faut
s'attaquer à cela maintenant pour
pouvoir avoir une véritable reprise
économique en france
sinon on aura pas de reprise en u même
pas on aura une reprise en l c'est à
dire qu on mettra des années peut-être
dix ans a retrouvé le niveau de
croissance qu'on avait en 2019
benjamin a marre je vous sent bouillir d
un taux d'impôt trop élevé en france une
réforme du code de travail dans
n'imagine que vous n'êtes pas du tout
d'accord non je ne suis pas du tout en
colère je suis habitué au juke box crié
des libéraux vous inquiétez pas je ne
suis pas du bureau de confédérale de la
cgt je fais partie de la commission
exécutive confédérale
vous m'avez donné du galon
supplémentaire mais autrement pour
revenir sur le sujet pour revenir sur le
sujet les déclarations de monsieur roux
de bézieux ne sont pas prémonitoire
c'est révélateur d'une situation en
france quand le président du medef
chanter une comptine et bien derrière
vous avez le coeur des vestales qui
reprend régulièrement cette petite
musique
nous avons eu l'institut montaigne
aujourd'hui monsieur r là mais écoutez
c'est quand même incroyable c'est à dire
moi je trouve que c'est une mentalité de
charognards c'est à dire que vous avez
une crise sanitaire incroyable et
certains mais finalement comme seul
argument alors que les français vivent
une situation terrible de l'art il va
falloir travailler plus c'est quand même
très étonnant je vais donner des idées
aux libéraux français en
nouvelle-zélande
la première ministre jasmine garden en
train de proposer elle exactement
inverse c'est à dire de baisser le temps
de travail en proposant la création de
jour férié en proposant la semaine de
quatre jours en se disant que justement
eh ben ça va permettre de doubler par
exemple le secteur touristique mais où
est donc cette petite cette petite
chanson qui est complètement à rebours
de l'histoire sociale
l'histoire sociale ça a été la baisse du
temps de travail pour obtenir des gains
de productivité et en plus ce qui est
sidérant quand même c'est de nous dire
qu'il faut augmenter le temps de travail
au moment même où les plans sociaux
s'annonce à l'horizon d'une façon de
plus en plus menaçante chez renault chez
conforama mais également dans plein
d'autres secteurs chez alinéa dans les
entreprises comme ceux michelin hc kharg
il sait lui que ce faire on a
effectivement des risques de plans
sociaux qui se présentait la cgt
d'ailleurs partout
interpelle pour dire attention il faut
conserver notre tissu industriel parce
que on a bien vu au moment des masques
des tests et des réparateurs que notre
puissance industrielle est à nu à cause
de délocalisation à cause de cette façon
de brader notre patrimoine industriel et
enfin l'argument de la fiscalité est
incroyable mais monsieur guerlain
je ne sais pas s'ils étaient dans un
abri antiatomique pendant la crise ne
notre notre modèle social qui permet de
financer par exemple activité partielle
ce qui limite l'impact social
quand on voit ce qui se passe aux
etats-unis par exemple eh bien il est
financé par justement cette fiscalité la
fiscalité
elle finance la solidarité elle finance
justement notre modèle social
le seul problème dans notre fiscalité
c'est effectivement la trop faible
fiscalité sur le capital et l'évasion
fiscale massive
ça ce sont des problèmes mais
visiblement on n'a pas les mêmes
diagnostic de façon très étonnante
philippe avant de revenir sur ses 35
heures parce que je voudrais vous faire
écouter justement les députés france
insoumise mettent-ils panneaux sur ce
point une petite réponse sur cette
dernière remarque de benjamin marc le
problème c'est l'évasion fiscale en
france concerne ses plus sincères à
mites livraison physique qu'elle n'y a
pas de chiffres sérieux vraiment qui
circulent là dessus il ya évidemment
l'évasion fiscale parce que la france
est un enfer fiscal il yaa taux
d'imposition qui découragent les gens
donc donc les gens qu 1h08 partir il
faut le comprendre il ya des paradis
fiscaux il ya beaucoup de parasites et
son qui sera en fait des pays qui ont
une fiscalité normale c'est pour ça que
les gens y vont il ya beaucoup de gens
qui vont s'installer en belgique parce
qu'il n'ya pas un impôt sur la fortune
ou défi où ils vont s'installer en
suisse
voilà la france est un enfer fiscal non
faut pas s'étonner que les gens partent
le meilleur façon de les garder c'est
d'avoir une spécialité qui soit dans la
norme française voilà une spécialité sur
les personnes créer une fiscalité sur
les entreprises se rendent aux prises
par exemple ont 50 et je les ai un petit
qu'aujourd'hui il ya les impôts sur la
production qui paissent l'équivalent de
3 2% de pib c'est le double de niveau
européen et en allemagne 0,4 pour cent
les impôts sur la production ça veut
dire que on ne taxe pas les bénéfices à
quai
on taxe le chiffre d'affaires même si
vous faites beaucoup de bénéfices ou
très peu de bénéfices
vous avez la même taxe et ses liens au
chiffre d'affaires et ça et ça ça
s'appelle sur l'entreprise et c'est
presque une prime à la délocalisation et
on le voit aujourd'hui avec renault qui
doit fermer six usines pour les mettre à
l'extérieur voilà donc il faut il faut
s'attaquer à ces problèmes il faut
s'attaquer à ces problèmes et c'est pas
avec plus d'étapes on va s'en sortir
voilà alors pour revenir sur ce sujet
des 35 heures parce que c'est un petit
peu le débat travailler plus pour
relancer l'économie mise à mal notamment
par ses cris du coc vide 19 je voudrais
vous faire écouter donc mathilde fans au
député france insoumise qui plaide pour
aller plus loin encore que ces 35 heures
on va avoir une explosion du chômage
donc face à l'explosion du chômage il ne
faut pas faire travailler les gens
toujours plus mais au contraire diminuer
le temps de travail la création des 35
heures est un des moments qui a eu le
plus de créations d'emplois dans notre
histoire récente
il faut diminuer le temps de travail
pour pouvoir travailler tout et tout
benjamin a marre vous à dakar faut aller
encore plus loin et travailler encore
moins que les 35 heures francs qu'ils
évoquent
chez les filles 32 heures ça a été un
moment des moments d'histoire qui a créé
le plus d'emplois qu'on est d'accord
avec ce diagnostic madame amara avant de
faire réagir philippe herlin alors
d'abord j'aimerais juste réagir ce qui
pèse sur les entreprises
c'est bien plus la halle l'impérieuse
nécessité de verser des dividendes aux
actionnaires
je rappelle que la france est championne
du monde dans la ruche des dividendes
aux actionnaires et qu'elle obtient
chaque année des résultats plus probants
la matière les riches vont très bien et
il ya un problème pour le capital qui
justement se rétribue plus que grâce sur
les 35 heures après je suis exactement
ce qu'a fait maintenant je vous rappelle
que et la cgt le porte à plusieurs
reprises de philippe martinez on a fait
état dans les médias la cgt porte le
modèle de la réduction du temps de
travail à 32 heures
bien évidemment mais avec ce triptyque
qui consiste à dire travailler tous
travailler mieux travailler moins bien
sûr qu'il est absurde de vouloir faire
travailler davantage ce qui déjà
travaille beaucoup
alors qu'on a un chômage important
l'histoire sociale elle a consisté
encore une fois je le répète à faire
baisser le temps de travail ce qui
permet de lutter contre le chômage et
d'obtenir des gains de productivité bien
évidemment n'en déplaise aux libéraux
pour qui les 35 heures sont responsables
de tout y compris de la disparition des
dinosaures
en réalité les 35 heures ont été le
moment où on a créé le plus massivement
d'emplois ces trente dernières années
à chaque fois que le patronat a demandé
des exonérations de cotisations eh bien
pour soi disant derrière doper l'emploi
et bien il ne sait qu'il sait il ne
s'est rien passé
souvenez-vous du petit pin's de monsieur
gattaz au moment du pacte de
responsabilité avec marc et un million
d'emplois créés et quand michel sapin
ministre de l'économie de l'époque le
v10
c'est une promesse monsieur battage
monsieur gattaz avait répondu non c'est
un pin's voilà donc si on veut créer des
emplois effectivement on baisse le temps
de travail la cgt portent cette
revendication très précise des 32 heures
philippe herlin votre réponse mais la
rue la baisse du temps de travail
aujourd'hui c'est serait ce qui pourra
les pires l'économie française parce que
déjà que les entreprises ont subi un
choc énorme et que le quoran à virus
si les salariés travaillent 32 heures
payées 35 ou payer 39
ça va faire encore augmenter les coûts
pour les entreprises
essam a précipité dans la faillite des
centaines de milliers d'entreprises donc
ce serait une catastrophe absolue donc
on met là on voit on se demande
on ne voit que la cgt qui se définit
comme révolutionnaire c'est à dire une
société qui veut détruire une
organisation qui veut détruire la
société démocratique et libérale que
nous avons moi je considère que aussi la
réalisation de la france a réussi sa
passe par la résolution ça passe ça
passe par la réduction du pouvoir des
syndicats en france et pas réparé par là
il parle des vraies libertés syndicats
c'est à la fin de ce qu'ils ont fait
c'est limité à un certain nombre de
centrales il faut une vraie liberté
syndicale et il faut baisser de 10
minutes de nuisance des syndicats a qui
passent leurs esclaves et indique son
nouveau on l'avait on l'a vu on l'avait
rixe en double renault sont deux villes
car ferme et non pas pour des raisons
sanitaires mais pour des questions mais
parce que la convocation avait été
envoyé par email plutôt que par courrier
ces voix là
la victoire de la cgt où ai je dit bravo
on peut applaudir havre à bonn belle
victoire est une belle victoire contre
l'emploi une contre l'entreprise
française
donc moi je dis qu'il ya strictement
rien à attendre d'un sale et qu'un
révolutionnaire qui veut détruire la
société démocratique et libérale et que
la rieuse radiation ça passera notamment
entre autres par la réduction du pouvoir
des syndicats et par une vraie de
légèreté syndicale qui n'existe pas
aujourd'hui en france le mot de la fin
pour benjamin marqué en meurent dans vie
je voulais vous faire réagir également
sur ses ces jours fériés que certains
parlent de supprimer mais je vous ai
tellement barras tous les lieux qui en
auraient le temps benjamin aa les y
réponde et les désirs de nos cieux erna
sont amusants mais pas content il se de
la fecq nous c'est monsieur guerlain
vous allez me communiquer votre adresse
mail on va vous envoyer le jugement de
sandouville
il vous n'avez pas lu il y a des choses
très précises dans ce jugement là
l'entreprise a été condamnée par le juge
du référé parce que au lieu de faire une
simple information on devait convoquer
en bonne et due forme le cs
le juge du référé à un événement
considéré que les élus du personnel
n'avaient pas du tout les mêmes comment
dire les bons éléments pour appréhender
la sécurité sanitaire
donc celui des libéraux qui consiste à
dire est qu'il y avait également de la
situation et des mesures qui ces tables
qui n'était pas bien arrivé ce sont des
mensonges
monsieur vous faites de la veille
syndicats sur le coup tandis que j'avais
dit sur le paradis fiscaux on comprend
bien qu'avec vous l'avez été toujours
nos placards philippe hervé s'agit
quasiment des notions de viella je
précise
merci j'ai profité d'un petit blanc
c'était pas facile
merci à tous les deux benjamins 1 marc
philippe herlin d'avoir été avec nous et
de débattre
chacun de vos idées on vous mettra
évidemment pas d'accord mais enfin c'est
le but des face-à-face merci en tout cas
à tous les deux un mot sur le bilan de
l'épidémie 1 2 coronavirus dans
l'hexagone à présent on compte un peu
plus de 28000 décès selon les chiffres
de la direction générale de la santé oms
comptes sont ni morts de plus lors des
24 dernières heures
nombre de personnes en réanimation
continue lui de baisser avec 100
personnes de moins par rapport à hier
reste avec nous dans quelques instants
nous partirons en suède la stratégie de
l'immunité collective face au co by 19
semble porter ses fruits et le pays s'en
tient à des recommandations à la
population et puis direction le canada
plutôt épargnée jusqu'ici sauf que la
belle province qui concentre le plus de
décès le déconfinement doit toutefois
commencé ce lundi
[Musique]
est ce qu'on sait combien d'enfants sont
victimes de ces violences et qui sont
concernés par ces drames qui se déroule
dans le huis clos familial pendant la
période actuelle il est difficile de
dire précisément combien d'enfants sont
concernés car en fait on a très peu de
visibilité
nous savons simplement que il y à des
situations effectivement qui s'aggrave
dans les familles il ya toutes les
classes sociales qui sont concernés par
la maltraitance il faut qu'on le dise
ils leur disent là le problème c'est que
dans le cas du confinement il n'y a plus
cet entourage et tout se fait à distance
ce qui fait qu'il est très difficile de
repérer par téléphone par visiophone ces
situations et notre inquiétude un porte
plutôt sur ce que vous pouvez non pas la
partie immergée de l'iceberg en fait
parce que les très difficile pour les
enfants malgré tout d'appeler le même
et dans ce cas là on n'entend rien ça se
fait totalement dans le silence
[Musique]
ici on écoute ceux qui ne sont pas
d'accord
ici on invite les plus compétents pas
seulement ceux qui parlent le plus fort
[Musique]
ici on reçoit c'est qu'on ne voit pas
ailleurs
[Musique]
parce qu'ici c'est interdit d'interdire
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
est-ce qu'on a une idée d'augmentation
ou pas des signes ici d'aujourd'hui en
france les cours et les violences
n'existait avant le confinement et
pendant ce compliment c'est vrai qu'il
ya sept ce cadre lecture les taux de
féminicide a plus que je dis pas doublé
mais bien monté
forcément on n'a pas encore tous les
chiffres officiels c'est très difficile
bourreau n'est jamais d âme et loi
finalement c'est le confinement dans le
confinement
cela veut dire qu'il ya huit clos au
sein des foyers
et forcément donc les femmes victimes de
violences de nombreux emplois à 3
[Musique]
bonsoir à tous bienvenue si vous nous
rejoignez en direct sur rt france 20h30
heure française
en europe un pays fait donc cavalier
seul la suède elle n'a jamais confirmé
sa population seuls des recommandations
ont été donnés les chiffres eux sont là
3700 décès liés aux copies de 19
un bilan bien supérieur à celui de ses
voisins scandinaves mais le gouvernement
suédois le martèle il s'agit d'une
stratégie à long terme
les éclaircissements avec walid bennani
contrairement aux autres grandes
capitales européennes les rues de
stockholm n'ont jamais étaient désertes
ces deux derniers mois
allez à la pandémie qui touche la
majorité des pays du monde y compris le
leur les suédois semble presque épargnée
par cette situation inédite
de son côté le gouvernement ne cesse de
rappeler dans ses discours
sa ligne directrice cette lutte contre
le coc u19 est un marathon et les
mesures prises ont donc été choisis
parce que nous croyons fermement
qu'elles sont viables à long terme
la vie ne se déroule pas normalement en
suède karine en est pourtant pas de
confinement les bars les restaurants les
commerces sont restés ouverts tout comme
les écoles primaires et les collèges
face à la crise sanitaire les autorités
ont misé sur le bon sens et la
solidarité nationale les règles de
distanciation sociales sont conseillés
pas de masque obligatoire le travail à
domicile et encourager les personnes
âgées de plus de 70 ans sont incités à
s'isoler
seuls les rassemblements de plus de 50
personnes et les visites en maison de
retraite sont interdits je pense que la
stratégie suédoise s'est avéré durable
je veux dire que nous obtenions des
chiffres maintenant que les gens
adhèrent de plus en plus à nos conseils
il est apparemment assez facile de
commencer un confinement
mais l'arrêté est beaucoup plus
difficile de convaincre la population
qu'un jour vous êtes censé faire ceci et
le lendemain vous êtes censé faire autre
chose et je pense que cela revient à la
question de la durabilité la durabilité
est très importante lorsque vous
voyez avec la santé publique et les
maladies transmissibles anticiper une
deuxième vague
la stratégie de la suède repose sur
l'idée que le virus ne va pas
disparaître de sitôt et qu'il doit
circuler lentement on sent de la société
pour ne pas engorger les services
hospitaliers avec 1000 son lit
disponible
la capacité d'accueil a été doublé dans
les unités de réanimation le système de
santé suédois se prépare à une situation
qui pourrait durer plusieurs mois
nous prévoyons de travailler ainsi
pendant tout l'été et nous devrons
ensuite continuer à analyser l'évolution
de la pandémie et nous le faisons chaque
jour chaque semaine pour voir où nous
allons si le nombre de malades augmente
si nous avons plus de patients et nous
continuerons à le faire aussi longtemps
que nécessaire probablement toute
l'année une sérénité symbolisée par la
cote de popularité en hausse du
gouvernement selon l'institut de sondage
nos bus 63 % des suédois sont satisfaits
de l'actuelle gestion de la crise
sanitaire avec un bond de 20% en un mois
fin avril le responsable des programmes
d'urgence de l'om est-ce déclaré que la
suède pourrait servir de futurs modèles
en matière de lutte contre le coc vie 19
et pourtant masse lynn bourne
journaliste et historien la stratégie du
gouvernement était la plus adaptée à la
population suédoise
on voit que le nombre de décès est quand
même assez haut et ça paie pas
inquiétant en même temps on voit aussi
que comme le premier ministre dit il
faut voir ça de nombreux termes qu'est
ce qui va être le résultat dans un nom
ça c'est un deuxième réflexion je
voudrais aussi dire une troisième
réflexion c'est que est ce que ça aurait
été possible en suède de faire autrement
que d'avoir cette politique cette
stratégie qu'on a fait parce que chaque
pays n'est pas on peut pas comparer le
pays facilement il ya des différences
culturelles et historiques entre chaque
pays on n'a pas les grandes crises
catastrophe comme dans beaucoup d'autres
pays en europe donc on est un peu les
dés que être on fermait confinés comme
dans d'autres pays
ça serait très difficile les jambes ont
probablement par accepter ça de la même
façon d'abord deuxièmement je pense
qu'il ya une côte et si on peut dire
d'abord pragmatique mais aussi
rationaliste scientifique en suède qui
est très fort dit si les gouvernements
et les responsables disent qu elles on
peut avoir une politique qui répond aux
demandes scientifique elle ce qui est
scientifique on prétend d'être
scientifique
les jambes ont accepté ça et évidemment
pour la troisième chose si on est moins
en fermées et les autorités disent que
c'est c'est bien
que c'est ces scientifiques évidemment
les jambes allaient tenir à cette
politique au canada l'épidémie de kovy
19 continue d'inquiéter plus
particulièrement dans la province
francophone du québec la ville de
montréal est aujourd'hui l'une des dix
villes du monde où le virus a fait le
plus de morts par habitant depuis lundi
plusieurs barrages permettant forces de
l'ordre de contrôler les allées venues
entre les provinces ont été levées une
situation qui inquiète de plus en plus
les voisins du québec le président et
directeur général de l'alliance de
l'industrie touristique du québec tente
de rassurer
il ne faut pas stigmatiser montréal
parce que cela représente 40 à 60% du
marché touristique pour les régions mais
il faut comprendre l'inquiétude et la
calmer progressivement travaille en
partenariat avec les municipalités le
ministère du tourisme est les chambres
de commerce locales sachant que le
tourisme un apport économique important
dans chacune des régions et pour en
parler nous sommes avec à jérôme
blanchet gravel correspondant au canada
pour spoutnik bon soit jérôme blanchet
gravel merci d'être avec nous à montréal
a donc le canada qui ne vivent pas
manifestement la crise sanitaire
de la même façon pourquoi la ville de
montréal et elle touché de la sorte
plusieurs explications parmi les plus
cités je vous dirais d'avoir le québec
compte de très très nombreuses personnes
âgées ont le vu le système d'hébergement
des aînés complètement à revoir ses
stocks
une situation qui ressemble à celle de
la france donc les centres de
personnages et non autonomes ont été
très légèrement touchée donc c'est soit
le nombre élevé de personnes âgées
explique d'abord que montréal est aussi
touché 1 deuxièmement la distanciation
sociale qui aurait été plus difficile à
appliquer dans certains quartiers dans
des quartiers peut-être un peu moins et
riche donc ceci la deuxième explication
troisième explication peut-être une plus
grande réticence des canadiens français
des québécois appliquée
les mesures de confinement peut être les
restes d'un certain esprit latin qui
aurait fait en sorte que les gens c'est
ça était plus raide saint appliqué les
consignes que dans le canada anglais
ou peut-être que les gens ont une
culture peu plus puritaine plus proche
de certaines hygiénisme si je faisais
moi pourtant vous nous confirmer les
mêmes mesures de confinement ont été
mises en place partout dans le pays
à peu près c'est à dire que ce sont les
provinces qui ont qui ont été appelés à
développer les programmes d'urgence des
programmes de protection des populations
donc chaque province avait son plein
donc la santé c'est un domaine de
compétence provinciale au canada donc
évidemment il y quelques divergences
mais on peut dire que dans l'ensemble la
fédération les provinces ont appliqué
sensiblement le même programme donc la
déception est d'autant plus grande au
québec on se pose des questions pourquoi
le québec 1 et plus toucher à ce point
là dont je viens de vous donner des
facteurs explicatifs mais je vous dis
que au départ il y avait un fort vent
d'optimisme au québec les québécois ont
eu l'impression de se retrouver autour
d'une cause commune et malheureusement
avec le temps cet optimisme la s'est
complètement dégonflé est évidemment une
certaine examen de conscience qui va
devoir elle fait au québec parce que de
22% de la population et au québec
ce que ces 22 % la population canadienne
mais si plus de 50 % des cas dans
l'ensemble la fédération donc alors en
france nous avons une règle
on ne peut pas dépasser les fameux 100
km ça arrange peut-être certains en
province un qui sont en zone verte ne
pas voir tous ces parisiens débarquer
sur leur territoire est ce que la
crainte et la même par exemple de ne pas
voir justement les gens de montréal les
habitants de montréal débarquer dans des
zones moins touchés vous l'avez dit du
québec
oui je te fais c'est un peu cocasse
parce que bon et comment c'est ça il ya
un décalage
entre ce qu'on appelle la province ici
on dit les régions en france on dit la
province qui la métropole montréal le g
en rien donc oui plusieurs maires des
municipalités des organismes régionaux
qui ont exprimé des craintes de voir les
montréalais débarqué à montréal
dans les régions c'est à dire un peu
comme un peu comme des zombies le voyez
qu'ils seraient là pour les contaminés
en même temps les régions et bien pu
épargner artificiellement par la
pandémie parce que de nombreux barrages
routiers ont été mis en place
donc certains disent on ne veut pas de
deuxième vague au québec
mais ce que certains répondent c'est ce
ne soit pas une deuxième vague en région
ça va être une première vague parce que
les régions ont été préservés
officiellement de saut et en même temps
tu es s'il fallait que le mondial est
amené à il n'avait pas passé dans
vacances estivales dans les régions ce
serait une petite catastrophe économique
pour le tourisme pour l'économie des
régions donc lieu du bourg est il contre
dans cette situation là donc les gens
ont peur mais en même temps ils ont
aussi pas pour leurs économies alors il
ya le voisin américain également est ce
qui l'inquiète et frontières sont
toujours fermé les frontières sont
fermées je voudrais que ce qui inquiète
encore un plus et à l'immigration
clandestine qui a été qui n'eut
contrôler maintenant depuis depuis une
date les simples dont j'oublie que
j'oublie jacquemin mais justin trudeau
est beaucoup critiqué pour ça même
aujourd'hui parce que beaucoup hésitent
et affrontera fermer les frontières avec
les états unis est aussi à lui à bloquer
l'immigration clandestine qui s'est
poursuivie le pendant de nombreuses
semaines
même en plein en pleine pandémie donc
des migrants clandestins qui sont entrés
au canada chaque jour des dizaines avec
peut-être le virus on sait qu'au début
il n'était pas testé finalement
maintenant ils le sont ils ont ils on a
passé un examen santé ce sont des
demandeurs d'asile et est ce qu'on a pu
découvrir qu'ils demandent c'est un peu
le portrait c'est que plusieurs
demandeurs d'asile qui sont venus
clandestinement il ya quelques années
travail ménard au front
offrant des récentes de la synergie non
autonomes donc oui je sais jamais si je
n'ai système alors il ya aussi un
constat économique difficile il ya
quelques jours le 16 mai la compagnie
air canada a lancé le licenciement de
20000 employés sur 38 mills a dû être un
sacré séisme pour le canada cette
nouvelle qui de fait non l'économie
canadienne va être donc toutes les
économies allemande ou presque cela va
être durement affectée par par la
situation au québec en particulier si
les pme mais là les pme a donc les
petites moyennes entreprises qui
représentent à peu près comme 85% du
secteur privé donc vous imaginez est à
peu près la moitié des pme ont déjà mis
des gens à pied
donc on recommence à peine ressentir les
effets économiques de la crise seront
vraiment dans les prochaines semaines
comme ailleurs dans le monde qu'on va
découvrir les finis diversité des
domaines des travailleurs touchés par la
crise pendant ce temps là justin trudeau
multiplie les aides gouvernementales
c'est une forme une sorte d'orgie
financière là c'est à dire que vraiment
justin trudeau est en train de manger
car un déficit historique et très l'état
qui exclut aussi pour ça parce que c'est
peut-être pas trop généreux led led de
discernement donc certains ont craint
que les canadiens et aux canadiennes se
retrouvent dans le rouge
merci à vous jérôme blanchet gravel
d'avoir été avec nous avoir parlé de la
situation au canada
la crise sanitaire de plus en plus
graves
au daghestan république russe située
dans le sud du pays plus de 40 médecins
sont décédés récemment des suites d'une
pneumonie après avoir contracté le coc
u19 et l'information révélée par le
ministre de la santé local
les précisions à moscou de notre
correspondant antoine claireaux oui les
autorités ont souligné à de nombreuses
reprises les différentes régions de
russie ne sont pas atteintes de la même
façon par cette pandémie
parmi les régions les plus touchées il y
a donc le daghestan cette république
russe située dans le nord du caucase où
de nombreux personnages santé ils sont
morts de pneumonie ou des suites du
gorna virus d'après le ministre de la
santé de la région alors plusieurs
facteurs en sont la cause il ya le
manque de respect des règles de
confinement ou encore l'auto médication
et le recours trop tardif aux soins
médicaux et vladimir poutine s'en est
inquiété lors de sa dernière vision
conférence vous dégustez ni proust la
situation daguestan est difficile de
plus en plus de cas d'infection et de
complications graves sont identifiés et
ces derniers jours le système de santé
de la région a été mise à rude épreuve
malgré les efforts des roues et des
médecins et des infirmiers le nombre de
tragédies a augmenté y compris au sein
du personnel soignant
en outre on dit que les soins médicaux
nécessaires ne sont pas toujours et
partout disponibles en temps voulu et
dans leur intégralité
en effet les infrastructures médicales
sur place ne sont pas celles de la
capitale même si la construction dans
cette région de trois nouveaux complexes
médicaux a été annoncée par exemple la
russie à cette approche on a déjà dit de
tester un maximum de monde plus de 7
millions 2,8 de tests ont déjà été
réalisés mais qu'est ce temps le nombre
de tests menés est deux fois moindre que
prévu faute de laboratoire pour pouvoir
analyser les échantillons
en conséquence le personnel médical sur
place prêtent tous les patients de la
même manière qu'il s'agisse de cas
confirmés ou non en attendant reste donc
la prévention pour tenter d'enrayer la
propagation du virus
même la superstar de la mma ravi bloom a
commis neuf est monté au créneau pour
appeler ses combats
trilles ott a respecté le confinement
dans le reste du pays
la lente décrue se confirme et pour la
première fois depuis le début de cette
crise il ya davantage de guérison
enregistré que deux nouveaux cas ces
dernières 24 heures mais comme on vient
de le voir la situation est loin d'être
homogène partout l impact financier du
coronavirus est de plus en plus visible
en afrique du sud les distributions de
colis alimentaires se multiplient pour
les plus démunis
le confinement a mis en place depuis le
27 mars limite fortement l'activité
économique privé de travail
de nombreux sud africains sont dans
l'obligation de recourir à la solidarité
pour subvenir aux besoins de leurs
foyers
la nourriture que j'ai reçu ici m'aidera
beaucoup car nous n'avions pas de
nourriture à la maison les choses sont
difficiles parce que nous sommes
associés à la maison et ne pouvons pas
aller travailler
nous ne recevons plus d'argent de notre
employeur alors ces colis alimentaires
rendront la vie meilleure et dans le
reste de l'actualité internationale
l'onu déclare que l'état d'israël doit
abandonner ses menaces d'annexion une
annonce faite après la déclaration de
mahmoud abbas le président palestinien
de mettre fin à sa coopération
sécuritaire avec les américains et les
israéliens
une annexion jugée contraire au droit
international pour beaucoup mes disques
et fit un retrait de tous les accords
passés avec israël et les états unis
c'est la décision palestinienne annoncé
par mahmoud abbas mardi à ramallah
la raison de cette rupture la volonté de
benyamin nétanyahou d'annexer dépend de
la cisjordanie
le gouvernement palestinien estime que
le projet israélien est contraire aux
espoirs de paix dans la région
premièrement l'organisation de
libération de la palestine et des tas de
palestine sont absous à compter
d'aujourd'hui de tous les accords et
arrangements avec les gouvernements
américain et israélien et de tous les
engagements
basé sur ces accords et arrangements
y compris ceux relatifs à la sécurité
deuxièmement l'autorité d'occupation
israélienne à partir d'aujourd'hui doit
assumer toutes les responsabilités et
obligations devant la communauté
internationale en tant que puissance
occupante sur le territoire de l'état
occupés de palestine avec toutes ses
conséquences et répercussions basée sur
le droit international
dans le même temps le chef de la
diplomatie européenne met en garde
israël au sujet de son projet d'annexion
en rappelant notamment à l'état hébreu
ses obligations en matière de droit
international
nous demandons instamment à israël de
s'abstenir de toute décision unilatérale
qui conduirait à l'annexion de tout
territoire palestinien occupé et qui
serait en tant que tel contraire au
droit international dans le passé
mahmoud abbas avait déjà menacé de
sortir de la coopération sécuritaire
avec israël
il avait notamment évoqué la fin de
toutes les relations avec tel-aviv et
washington après la présentation du plan
de paix de donald trump censé résoudre
le conflit israélo palestinien
celui ci prévoit l'annexion des colonies
et de la vallée du jourdain qui
représente environ 30 % de la
cisjordanie et pour michel raimbault
ancien ambassadeur de france il fallait
s'attendre à cette décision
c'était prévisible d'ailleurs ce avaient
été annoncées mais jamais réalisées
paiement on ne sait jamais quand quelque
chose est annoncée s'est pas vraiment
mis en oeuvre l'enfant en tout cas c'est
pas une décision surprenante
ça signifie l'irlande rôle l'enterrement
première classe et qui mettaient en fait
tout le problème la solution du problème
palestinien et centrant sur tôt 2e
données principal recours la négociation
secondaire le renoncement à la distance
armes et la renonciation à l'arc dans sa
peau et puis deuxièmement la solution à
deux états en fait les deux pistes sont
annulés pour moi puisque seules les îles
palestiniens ont essayé d'explorer cd m
rien n'est absolument pas donné de
réponse il va dessiner en conception et
palestiniens des conceptions des
israéliens n'ont fait aucune concession
en contrepartie rester avec nous dans
quelques instants nous parlerons de
l'annulation de la dette africaine
plaidé par cinq présidents du continent
hier lors d'un débat en ligne une
priorité selon eux afin de faire face
aux conséquences économiques dramatiques
dans le sillage du virus
et puis direction le maroc qui maintient
le confinement jusqu'au 10 juin
la situation sanitaire est stable mais
pas totalement rassurante a précisé le
chef du gouvernement
[Musique]
ici on écrire ce qu'ils ne sont pas
d'accord
ici on invite les plus compétents pas
seulement ceux qui parlent le plus fort
[Musique]
ici on reçoit c'est qu'on ne voit pas
ailleurs
[Musique]
alors ce qui si c'est interdit
d'interdire
[Musique]
l'écologie ce n'est pas de la politique
du dernier rapport du giec sur les
océans les jetons on est dans une espèce
de déni collectif on ne veut pas croire
ce qu'on sait et scientifiques parlent
comme anne de la sixième extinction de
la vie sur terre
sixième extinction de la vie sur terre
il ya d'autres experts qui contestent
non résidents dans 96 personnes non non
c'est pas vrai il ya des crimes à tous
et non ce n'est pas rien à part il ya
des gens qui ne sont pas des chercheurs
qui parlent que la presse met en avant
parce que il faut que du débat le gars
plus de débats aujourd'hui ya plus aucun
débat ce changement climatique et on va
faire un vrai par une catastrophe on va
vers une vraie catastrophe et on est
incapable d'en prendre conscience
mais ce n'est pas de pessimisme tout
comprendre ce qui va arriver pour moi je
pense qu'on est comme une guerre
aujourd'hui on est entré en guerre
contre nos façons vu et l'ennemi y'en a
pas d'ennemis l'ennemi c'est nous
[Musique]
vous parlez de résilience comment est-ce
qu'on pourrait le définir
c'est après un traumatisme qu'est ce
qu'on sait combien on reste traumatisée
bien on cherche en soi et autour de soi
quels sont les facteurs qui vont
permettre de reprendre un nouveau
développement est l'un font 42
résilience la catastrophe économique
dont on parle
elle est lié directement au confinement
c'est à dire à la mise en coma
artificiel de l'économie catastrophe ça
veut dire à côté
date à ce trop fine il ya un tournant
mais on se remet à vivre mais dans une
autre direction c'est la première fois
dans l'histoire de l'humanité que pour
sauver des vies humaines en ruines
la moitié de la planète jamais on a fait
ça jamais quel une décision à
vraisemblable pour vous ça dépend telles
valeurs on attribue à la mort la vie
humaine
si on considère que la vie humaine est
plus précieuse que l'économie on a bien
fait mais si on considère que maintenant
il va y avoir des catastrophes humaines
individuelles avec cette décision
alors je sais pas c'est un débat n'aura
un débat éthique
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
est ce qu'on sait combien d'enfants sont
victimes de ces violences et qui sont
concernés par ces drames qui se déroule
dans le huis clos familial pendant la
période actuelle il est difficile de
dire précisément combien d'enfants sont
concernés car en fait on a très peu de
visibilité
nous savons simplement que il y à des
situations effectivement qui s'aggrave
dans les familles il ya toutes les
classes sociales qui sont concernés par
la maltraitance il faut qu'on le dise
ils redisent là le problème c'est que
dans le cas du confinement il n'y a plus
cet entourage et tout se fait à distance
ce qui fait qu'il est très difficile de
repérer par téléphone par visiophone ces
situations et notre inquiétude un porte
plutôt sur ce que vous pouvez non pas la
partie immergée de l'iceberg en fait
parce que les très difficile pour les
enfants malgré tout d'appeler le même
et dans ce cas là on n'entend rien ça se
fait totalement dans le silence
nous allons évoquer ici les sujets
stratégiques pour notre pays et sur ces
dossiers sensibles
je vais partager avec vous une
interprétation la croissance des pays
émergents
la stagnation des pays occidentaux et le
ralentissement de ceux en développement
ont rendu la compétition économique
internationale
brut 1 soyons clairs dans la guerre
économique
tous les coups sont permis la stratégie
de conquête de marchés à l'exportation
s'appuie sur une politique offensive de
pillages deux fleurons du secteur sera
touche le succès passe toujours par la
connaissance parfaite de son adversaire
en jouant sur quatre critères clés
l'argent l'idéologie légaux et la
compromission
ce phénomène il est mondial on le
retrouve partout
c'est pourquoi on est frappé par la
naïveté des personnels et d'encadrement
principe ce qu' il n'existe sur la
planète
beaucoup d'acteurs chez qui est sans
aucune hésitation ni morale
la fin justifie les moyens
[Musique]
l'afrique qui compte 1 1 % de cas dans
le monde sait très peu comment vous
l'expliquez nous devons considérer que
les chiffres sont sous-estimés mais ne
sont pas encore au niveau où se trouve
par exemple l'europe ou les états unis
quelle stratégie vous avez déployés dans
le sud kivu pour limiter la propagation
du virus on a proposé à ce qu'est le
confinement puisse être sélectif est
concerné seulement des personnes âgées à
haut risque de complication pour
sensibiliser la population ça l'est
beaucoup plus facilement puisqu'on
venait de sortir d'une épidémie à ebola
qui exige également la distanciation
social lavage des mains que si on aura
affaire à deux épidémies aussi
dangereuse qui est beau la et
coronavirus ça pourrait être très très
difficile pour
[Musique]
tous
[Applaudissements]
ce contexte de crise sanitaire mondiale
quel rôle doit selon vous jouez à lévis
mais quel rôle joue-t-elle dans les
faits les villes tout comme les états
ils étaient pas préparés
mais les villes elles se sont connectés
tout de suite entre elles pour voir
comment elles pouvaient coopérer
il ya eu l'envoi des beaucoup de des
masques des matériels médicaux d'une
commune à l'autre selon vous à quoi
pourront ressembler les il commence
quelques courses transformé après la
pandémie la crise maintenant à fait bien
comprendre qu'on peut pas s'oublier des
banlieues on peut pas oublier les
quartiers pauvres parce que
véritablement être en partie de la vie
donc les grandes villes quand il se
connecte
elle ne part pas seulement d'elle même
elle parle aussi de comment créer cette
cercle vertueux avec les villes des
alentours
[Musique]
c'est chacun pour soi dieu pour tous
petit coup politique n'a jamais été
obligé de dire la vérité d idée
courageuse des mots qui cote la haine
soir vient des lignes aujourd'hui on a
une gauche l'extrême
tous les témoins de notre époque sont
dans la grande interview on va parler
évidemment de l'impact économique de
cette pandémie
est ce que tous les pays africains vont
être impactés continent voire voit
vraiment une de ses pires années de ces
trente dernières même si les
conséquences selon différentes selon les
pays
nous avons là une situation où pour
sauver les économies africaines il va
falloir créer de la liquidité il faut de
l'argent pour pouvoir se tirer
d'affaires pendant cette année 73
millions de personnes touchées quand
même par la crise alimentaire dans
quelle mesure cette pandémie du colis de
19 risque d'aggraver les choses
associer la troisième crise parce que le
pouvoir la solitaire qui est là et la
crise économique nous allons avoir une
crise de sécurité alimentaire
[Musique]
nenê
bonsoir à tous merci nous rejoindre pour
cette deuxième heure d'émission il est
21 heures heure de paris tout de suite
voici les titres de l'actualité de ce
mercredi 20 mai c'était le 13 avril
dernier emmanuel macron parlé d' annuler
massivement les dettes des pays
africains lors d'un débat en ligne
organisé hier cinq présidents africains
ont plaidé également pour cette
annulation
même si le continent semblent quelque
peu épargnée face au co vite 19 les
dirigeants évoquent une priorité pour
l'économie
faut-il annuler les dettes des pays
africains on en parlera dans quelques
instants avec nos deux invités jusqu'au
10 juin au maroc pas de relâchement
l'état d'urgence sanitaire est prolongée
ce qui signifie la poursuite du
confinement
une décision justifiée par la présence
de foyers épidémiologique industriels ou
familiaux port du masque et
distanciation sociale reste de rigueur
alors que se profilent aïd al fitr et le
nez c'est cela nécessaire relance
économique
[Musique]
le second tour des municipales aura-t-il
lieu fin juin c'était l'objet du conseil
des ministres aujourd'hui hier le
conseil scientifique a donné imprudence
vers edouard philippe doit rencontrer ce
soir les responsables des partis
le ministre de la santé lui s'est engagé
pour un renouveau de l'hôpital public
[Musique]
si le comique 19 semble en partie
épargné d'afrique les conséquences
économiques de la pandémie s'annonce
très grave pour le continent africain il
pourrait connaître une récession pour la
première fois en un quart de siècle
dans ce contexte cinq présidents
demandent l'annulation des dettes
africaines
[Musique]
[Rires]
pris dans ce contexte de crise sanitaire
inédite et face à des conséquences
économiques qui s'annoncent très grave
alors faut-il annuler les dettes
africaines
pour en parler nous sommes avec nos deux
invités m jid el guerrab député lt comme
liberté et territoires de la 9e
circonscription des français établis
hors de france bonsoir à vous merci
d'être en direct avec nous à ses côtés
pour en parler makhoudia diouf
géopolitologue cordes coordonnateur
pardon du collectif sortir du franc cfa
bonsoir à vous merci également d'être en
direct donc cette réunion un des cinq
présidents qui demandent qu'est avant
l'annulation de la dette des dettes
plutôt africaine est ce que c'est une
demande légitime pour vous amuser de el
guerrab absolument la la dette africaine
est une est une
comment dire est un serez là
l'annulation serait un ballon d'oxygène
qu'on pourrait offrir aux états
africains notamment en matière
budgétaire
quand on sait par exemple qu'un pays
comme le ghana la dette le remboursement
de sa dette annuelle ça représente cette
fois le budget de la santé
donc il faut il faut absolument parvenir
à trouver des voies pour redonner cette
puissance budgétaire aux pays africains
pour investir dans leur santé investir
dans les infrastructures sanitaires dans
leur éducation etc pour faire face aux
défis à venir celui de la crise du
coronavirus mais au delà défis de
l'éducation des filles de la culture le
défi de la sécurité le défi des
infrastructures donc
donc voila nous on plaide en tout cas
moi je fais partie des parlementaires
qui plaît de manière très forte pour
qu'on en arrive à pas simplement une un
rééchelonnement ou alors une
transformation de cette dette non une
annulation pure et simple
on enverra en tout cas les arguments
pendant ce débat
on va voir la vie de makhoudia dit ouf
vous êtes d'accord avec angie de el
guerrab il faut tout simplement annuler
la dette nous il ya plus de nuances de
votre côté effectivement de mon côté il
ya plus de nuances alors déjà en fait il
faut mettre
il faut mettre les choses dans leur
contexte on a des chefs d'état africains
qui demandent qu'on va dire la nation de
la dette des pays africains mais son
regard de le proposer au départ et
maquereau qui pose le débat et de
l'éducation sete et la dette et moi ce
qu'il sait qui c'est qui me dérange
c'est que si vous souvenez bien je
voulais faire un petit retour en arrière
le 19 décembre 2019 les chefs d'état à
se câliner à dakar leur nous sommes dans
une conférence sur la dette et donc ils
se sont vantés d'être des pays endettés
et donc toi trois mois après avec
quelques mois après on voit c'est une
chef d'état réclamée en tout cas demandé
l'annulation de la dette qu'ils
n'obtiendront pas et donc moi ce qui me
gêne bien entendu que je suis comme tout
le monde je suis d'accord que l'afrique
soir en jeu soutenu par la tête de koné
ce qui me gêne en arrivant c'est la
méthode aujourd'hui les africains sont
endettés pas design de la face me disait
de la chine
donc si elle demandait à faire il ne
faut surtout pas les maquereaux il faut
aller vers la chine est pour le moment
j'attends pas en fait nos chefs d'état
africains
c'est une démarche que dit bleu clair
vers les partenaires chinois et donc je
me dis est ce que tout ça n'est certes
pas une façon de enfin justice et la
récupération africaine donc voilà donc
bien entendu je suis pour l'anniversaire
de la dédicace africain mais la méthode
en tout cas il a préconisé par des chefs
d'état comme alassane ouattara comme
macky sall du sénégal et la méthode de
cette méthode me gêne alors justement
macau diadhiou je vous propose d'écouter
le président kenyan qui lui aussi
justement fait référence d'une certaine
manière à la chine
il est donc naturel de nous aider
dit il écoutez le c'est un phénomène qui
aimait ordaz flics et qui pourtant
frappe l'afrique le plus durement
il est donc naturel de nous aider voilà
m jid el guerrab le président kenya qui
fait référence aussi à cette dette
vis-à-vis également de la chine donald
trump lui aussi d'ailleurs dit il
faudrait faire payer la chine concernant
l'afrique vous êtes d'accord avec ce
postulat ou au contraire tout le monde
doit s'y mettre
européens en tête le premier aujourd'hui
la première puissance qui détient
effectivement la dette africaine 40% de
la dette africaine
alors que la france s'est à peine 10%
c'est la chine est donc effectivement
moi je suis d'accord avec le président
du collectif quand il dit que
effectivement le l'enjeu il est plus il
s'est déplacé l'enjeu maintenant est des
plus de se désendetter à l'égard des
pays asiatiques comme la chine que des
pays européens mais comme je viens de
l'expliquer si vous vous désendetter de
manière massive via le club le club de
rome et caetera et et que vous vous
permettez à ces états d'avoir un peu
plus d'oxygène budgétaire pour pouvoir
avoir d d d d investissement un peu plus
fort dans l'or dans leurs domaines
notamment sanitaires
voilà ça fera quelques milliards en plus
qu'il faut pas qu'il faut pas jeter d'un
revers de main mais c'est vrai que
l'enjeu aujourd'hui c'est est ce que la
chine va accepter aujourd'hui on en est
pas à l'annulation en est simplement un
moratoire
il ya un accord de toutes les grandes
puissances pour dire pendant un an deux
ans on arrête de payer la dette
on arrête de payer les traites
mensuelles qu'on doit à nos anonyme
sachant que dans la dette
il ya la dette publique détenue par les
états mis à la dette aussi privé et
aujourd'hui quand on regarde
effectivement comment est structuré
cette dette
on voit
manière très claire que la dette privée
la dette chinoise aujourd'hui constitue
une grosse partie une grosse part du
lion
effectivement là on va faire un peu de
pédagogie mako dia diouf comme le
souligne monsieur el guerrab la dette
privée et la dette bilatérale africaine
et ce n'est pas tout à fait la même
chose évidemment
alors effectivement je suis d'accord
avec ça ce n'est pas la même chose
maintenant il faut en fait de garder de
sous on part en profondeur sur le garder
bien on a comme des chefs d'état qui
sont endettés pour des projets défendus
fort qu'eux donc déjà je le garde pour
les bonnes questions pourquoi
aujourd'hui l'afrique est relégué alors
moi je peux parler un peu des pays dont
la france est pas parce que je les
connais parce que ces pays là sont sous
la domination entre dunes le colonial de
français qui empêcherait de toute marge
de manoeuvre
et là je cite l'étude en fait béninois
pakistanais qui dit on finance notre
notre développement par l'endettement et
mais il s'en vante
il s'en vende des chefs d'état africains
ses ventes en fait de s'endetter
argument que le fait que nos partenaires
nous tel de l'argent c'est parce qu on
est très bien gérée donc tout ça n'est
pas sérieux
maintenant je ne veux pas non plus qu'on
fasse des chinois le bleu bouc émissaire
parce que j'ai compris que dans les
propos de macron c'était voilà on voit
en fait tourner du curseur vers les
chinois toutes les affiches des tables
capsules et chinois la question les plus
compliqués la teste aujourd'hui c'est de
dire si les africains sont d'accord pour
dire que cette guerre est injuste et
illégitime
il ya une solution toute simple il peut
faire défaut donc c'est à dire en fait
le jeu des cdec
certains pays l'ont fait dans l'histoire
dont le syndic ne sont pas en fait les
thoniers deuxième 2 et deuxièmement
aujourd'hui on est en été comme je l ai
dit tout à l'heure
auprès d'acteurs de trouver où passait
vraiment aidé à des acteurs privés qui
viennent en afrique prêtent de l'argent
s'est passé
ces structures sont aujourd'hui pour
pour les internautes
ils sont en afrique pour nous faire les
poches je vais parler à fait le gamin
ils sont en effet couvert les profits et
une hausse
ils ne sont surtout pas la géologie
dans une logique en tout cas
d'annulation de la dette
maintenant pour les états notamment en
fait la chine la france des sous sont
très simples moi j'ai récemment un
communiqué pour dire que si la france
veut bien aider les africains de
nathalie est une bonne chose mais que la
phrase commence par rendre aux afriques
aux africains les milliards d'euros que
la phase de reprise africains ne france
et fars l'un des mérites du franc cfa
c'est un compte d'opérations qui est
doté à milliards la france pourrait
libérer ces fonds pour les pays
africains pour les soulager
angers pas depuis de longs mois donc
tout ça n'est pas n'est pas sérieux
d'être voilà soit la dette
on a une dette et moi je suis tous de
dire ça mais on n'aura pas d'émulation
donc je pense qu'on en débatte ou lien
là le moratoire d'accord ou lola mais
l'annulation
je ne crois pas parce que tout le monde
le sait tous ceux qui sont en face et
qu'aujourd'hui ils sont à l'affût pour
faire des affaires ils sont en effet que
faire
en tout cas les banques et les
institutions privées prête rarement y
compris à nous c'est un peu particulier
pour rien m jid el guerrab je vais
sélectionner un petit passage de ce qu'a
dit notre ami amadou dia diouf parfois
c'est vrai que l'afrique je parle sous
votre contrôle c'est vous qui l'avez dit
voilà se vante de faire des dettes pour
des raisons parfois loufoques je me fais
l'avocat du diable pourquoi l'europe
irait alors qu'elle même est en grande
difficulté on a une une dette qui est à
100 % du pib aujourd'hui annulerait la
dette de l'afrique alors voilà que
parfois ne gère pas les choses peut-être
là j'interprète peut-être vos propos
monsieur diouf mais comme un bon père de
famille finalement mais monsieur gnouf
tous les états ont besoin de dette y'a
pas ça n'existe pas un état qui
fonctionnerait sans dette la dette c'est
une nécessité pour nom est simple un
droit non mais non mais parce que quand
on dit si demain on annule la dette
africaine et ses états ça va pas les
empêcher d'aller s'endetter par ailleurs
auprès d'américains d'indiens
deux chinois etc deux russes pourquoi
parce que un état structurellement
fonctionne avec des recettes les
recettes ce sont les impôts et comme
vous le savez très bien dans les états
africains
l'économie est informel et l'assiette
pour recueillir les impôts est très très
très très faible les ressources minières
et cetera avec la gestion qu'en effet
été souvent assez chaotique donc
aujourd'hui sans vouloir critiquer la
structure étatique des états africains
ils ont besoin de la dette c'est un
c'est une nécessité aujourd'hui moi je
ne suis pas un
comment dire un quelqu'un de favorable à
l'endettement mais c'est une nécessité
pour fonctionner pour payer ses agents
pour ses infrastructures pour et c'est
l'éducation pour beaucoup de choses la
france s'endette les états européens
sans aide tous les états du monde sans
dette que ce soit sur les marchés privés
qu' il ya des états faut que vous et ça
à l'esprit à des états qui ne veulent
pas qu'on leur annuler leurs dettes
comme le nigeria et d'autres même le
rwanda et c'est pourquoi ils veulent pas
qu'on aura nul leur dette parce que ils
ont besoin de cette dette et si demain
on annule la dette
ils vont être très très mal notée sur
part justement toutes ses agences de
notation etc
et s'ils sont très mal notée ils
pourront plus relever de la dette et
donc pour eux annulé des dettes ça ça ça
représente un danger pour eux ils ont
ils sont scellés des états qui sont
plutôt bien géré généralement ne veulent
pas qu'on leur annuler la dette qu'on
l'a rééchelonne que on trouve des
solutions pour en sortir petit à petit
sans être trop comment dire trop saigné
oui donc il faut il faut faire attention
à ce qu'on a ce qu'on dit
la dette ça n'est pas forcément une
mauvaise chose parce que quand c'est une
dette pour investir dans l'éducation
pour investir dans la dent dans les
infrastructures pour investir dans la
santé pour investir dans dans l'avenir
d'un pays ce n'est pas ce n'est pas une
bonne chose
la mauvaise dette c'est la dette qui
payent le fonctionnement qui paye les
fonctionnaires qui paye un peu la
condition des états aujourd'hui qui sont
à majoritaire en afrique c'est à dire et
même j'ai envie de dire
en premier lieu l'état français est un
français s'endettent pour payer de son
fonctionnement ce qui est en soi une une
très mauvaise gestion donc le constat
que je fais pour les pays africains je
le fais aussi pour la france
merci à tous les deux en tout cas mj de
el guerrab et makhoudia diouf d'avoir
accepté donc de débattre sur ce thème
faut-il annuler la dette des pays
africains merci à vous deux est toujours
en afrique 1 le projet de loi mettant
fin au franc cfa été adopté aujourd'hui
en conseil des ministres perçu comme un
vestige de la françafrique il devient
désormais l'écho le projet de loi adopté
aujourd'hui va lycéens transformation la
réforme avait déjà amorcé fin décembre
entre emmanuel macron et des
gouvernements des états membres de
l'union monétaire ouest africaine
le franc cfa et est considéré comme un
signe de dépendance vis-à-vis de la
france par ses détracteurs
la porte parole du gouvernement sig est
en deuil a parlé d'un texte très attendu
le ministre de l'europe et des affaires
étrangères jean yves le drian ainsi que
le ministre de l'économie et des
finances bruno le maire ont présenté un
projet de loi qui était très attendu
très attendu par un certain nombre de
nos pays de nos partenaires africains en
particulier ceux des pays de l'union
monétaire africaine c'était lors d'une
visite officielle en côte d'ivoire en
décembre dernier dont qu'ils avaient
annoncé à cette occasion une réforme
historique de la coopération monétaire
qui devait aboutir à la fin du franc cfa
comme le président la république avait
pu le souligner cette fin symbolique
devait s'inscrire dans une dans un
renouvellement de la relation entre la
france et les pays africains
la direction présents le maroc ou le
confinement été prolongée lundi jusqu'au
10 juin
mise en place depuis le 20 mars dernier
il devait prendre fin ce mercredi 20 mai
alors comment le confinement est il géré
dans le pays la réponse en images
[Musique]
oh
à
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
mais pour en parler nous sommes avec
dane elec alaoui président de l'institut
marocain d'intelligence stratégique et
éditorialiste également pour la tribune
afrique bonsoir monsieur dream avec
allaoui merci d'être avec nous en direct
sur rt france alors le marocain va
prolonger jusqu'au 10 juin l'état
d'urgence sanitaire et le confinement la
situation sanitaire justifie t'elle
cette décision selon vous le maroc
depuis le 13 mars
lorsqu'il a décidé de boucler son espace
aérien plus une semaine plus tard de
prononcer le confinement généralisée à
appliquer sur instruction du roi
mohamed6 le principe de précaution
maximum on est donc dans le prolongement
de cette doctrine du principe de
précaution maximum en estimant que les
infrastructures sanitaires et des
principes de santé ne doivent pas être
mise sous pression et sous stress on
voit déjà les résultats de cette
politique de confinement strict qui est
appliquée dans le royaume chérifien
depuis depuis deux mois et quelques
maintenant moins 2 200 morts sept mille
personnes contaminées plus de 95 mythe
est certes une économie à l'arrêt mais
en tout cas pour l'instant la santé des
marocains est préservée je pense que
c'est la priorité absolue du chef de
l'état lorsqu'il a décidé que le
principe de précaution maximum serait
appliquée justement vous l'avez évoqué l
économie et le maroc perd 100 millions
d'euros par jour de confinement c'est
évidemment beaucoup d'argent pas de
concession donc pour l'économiste un peu
l'un vers 102 l'exemple suédois bien
plus au nord c'est un choix parfaitement
assumé en tout cas dans le discours
politique et dans ce discours des
pouvoirs publics c'est un choix qui est
clairement à subissent une situation qui
n'est pas différent de ce que beaucoup
d'autres pays ont entrepris en matière
de mise sous cloche de leurs économies
le temps que la pandémie soit soit soit
maîtrisé dans le cas du maroc de
surcroît il ya une connexion avec
l'économie mondiale avec le sud de
l'europe et des conditions ne sont pas
réunies aujourd'hui pour que l'économie
puisse redémarrer
allemands et paiement mais il ya des
indications et la presse se fait l'écho
du fait que certains secteurs de
l'économie devrait redémarrer avant même
que la levée du confinement ne soit
ordonnée par les autorités compétentes
quels sont justement ces secteurs parce
qu'on sait par exemple que le plus gros
fonds en danger un sont notamment les
usines avec des foyers de compte steam à
une contamination important alors sur
les usines il y à hadath quelques foyers
qui ont été relevés et qui ont
effectivement permis une contamination
beaucoup plus rapide parce que c'est un
lieu dans lequel il y a de la proximité
dans lequel il ya des échanges
je sais que une grande partie de
l'industrie est en train de s'organiser
pour pouvoir redémarrer avec des plans
de continuité des plans de continuation
avec des ses gestes ses fameux gestes
barrières qui seront organisés au sein
de toutes les usines devraient
simplement ce seront les entreprises des
plus stratégiques celles qui ont le plus
besoin qui sont le plus au coeur du
tissu productif du pays et qui ont le
plus grand taux d'employabilité qui
seront celles qui sont favorisés par les
pouvoirs publics en matière de
redémarrage
on imagine peut-être que la saison
estivale qui approche à grands pas avec
ses nombreux touristes on le sait au
maroc justifie peut-être un confinement
prolongé aujourd'hui vous comptez
certainement ouvrir les portes que la
situation soit peut-être à saigner au
maroc pour cette saison estivale
pour l'instant il n'y a pas d'indication
claire ni de communiqué de la parant
préfet de la branche de l'exécutif sur
quand est ce que les frontières sont
ouvertes mais il faut savoir que nous
savons également dépendants de la
réouverture de l'espace schengen
puisqu'une grande partie des touristes
qui convergent vers notamment les zones
estivale du royaume arrive de cette zone
schengen et que pour l'instant on ne
voit pas encore la réouverture de ces
endroits là mais évidemment le secteur
du tourisme est une grande préoccupation
pour le maroc il ya 10 à 13 millions
touristes en incluant les marocains
résidant à l'étranger qui viennent
chaque année au maroc
mais il ya aussi un autre facteur qui
est important qu'il convient de
souligner à ce stade c'est que chaque
année les marocains lorsqu'ils vont à
l'étranger dépenses plus de 2 milliards
d'euros dans des destinations étrangères
il est vraisemblable une très grande
partie de marocains passent les vacances
de cette année dans leur pays
peut-être que l'occasion de pouvoir le
redécouvrir il ya une grande communauté
marocaine également en france les
marocains qui ont sans doute très envie
de revenir dans leur pays d'origine cet
été est ce qu'il y à quelque chose qui
est prévue sur ce point qui est
envisagée à ce stade je pense que les
autorités sanitaires mais également des
organes de sécurité et puis la chefferie
du gouvernement évidemment sous la
tutelle du padd du palais royal n'a pas
encore donné d'indication claire sur
quelle serait la doctrine qui serait
appliqué à partir de cet été
je pense que tout le monde ressent de la
frustration de nombreux marocains
résidant à l'étranger qui voudraient
pouvoir revenir auprès de leurs familles
surtout que l'aïd el kébir arrive que ce
sont des moments de retrouvailles qui
sont importants pour les communautés
pour qu'elles puissent se retrouver mais
à ce stade il n'y a pas encore
d'indication claire sur ce que seront
les trois prochains mois on suivra donc
ces développements merci en tout cas
beaucoup d' el malek alaoui d'avoir été
avec nous en direct sûrs
rt france restez avec nous dans quelques
instants retour sur la gestion de la
crise du coronavirus en france après un
premier scrutin des élections
municipales 48 heures avant le début du
confinement
le second tour fait débat ensuite nous
parlerons de renault qui envisagerait de
fermer plusieurs sites en france selon
nos confrères du canard enchaîné
[Musique]
oui
vous parlez de résilience comment est-ce
qu'on pourrait le définir
c'est après un traumatisme qu'est ce
qu'on sait combien on reste traumatisée
bien on cherche en soi et autour de soi
quels sont les facteurs qui vont nous
permettre de reprendre un nouveau
développement est l'un fontaine de
résilience la catastrophe économique
dont on parle
elle est liée directement au confinement
c'est à dire à la mise en coma
artificiel de l'économie catastrophe ça
veut dire à côté
cata strophe là il ya un tournant et on
refera met à vivre mais dans une autre
direction c'est la première fois dans
l'histoire de l'humanité que pour sauver
des vies humaines en ruines
la moitié de la planète jamais on a fait
ça jamais clés d'une décision à
vraisemblable pour vous ça dépend quelle
valeur on attribuait la mort la vie
humaine
si on considère que la vie humaine est
plus précieuse que l'économie on a bien
fait mais si on considère que maintenant
il va y avoir des catastrophes humaines
individuelles avec cette décision
alors je sais pas le c'est un débat
n'aura un débat éthique
certains disent que nous ne sommes pas
une chaîne française
d'autres affirment même que nous ne
sommes pas journalistes mais vous
[Musique]
savez-vous vraiment qui nous sommes
les valeurs que nous défendons la
liberté
la liberté d'expression et d'opinion
nous défendons l'égalité l'égalité des
chances pour tous
[Musique]
nous sommes une équipe
nous sommes cette diversité qui fait la
france
et nous en sommes fiers
[Musique]
et si vous veniez voir par vous même
nous allons évoquer ici des sujets
stratégiques pour notre pays et sur ces
dossiers sensibles
je vais partager avec vous une
interprétation la croissance des pays
émergents
la stagnation des pays occidentaux et le
ralentissement de ceux en développement
ont rendu la compétition économique
internationale
brut 1 soyons clairs dans la guerre
économique
tous les poussons terme la stratégie de
conquête de marchés à l'exportation
s'appuie sur une politique offensive de
pillages deux fleurons du secteur
stratégique
le succès passe toujours par la
connaissance parfaite de son adversaire
en jouant sur quatre critères clés
l'argent l'idéologie légaux et la
compromission
ce phénomène il est mondial on le
retrouve partout
c'est pourquoi on est frappé par la
naïveté des personnels et d'encadrement
face à ce type de pratiques il n'existe
sur la planète
beaucoup d'acteurs tchéquie et sans
aucune hésitation ni morale la fin
justifie les moyens
[Musique]
ici on écoute ceux qui ne sont pas
d'accord
ici on invite les plus compétents pas
seulement ceux qui parlent le plus fort
[Musique]
ici on reçoit ce qu'on ne voit pas
ailleurs
alors ce coup ci c'est interdit
d'interdire
[Musique]
oh
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
bonsoir à tous bienvenue sur rt france
si vous nous rejoignez 21h30 heure
française tout d'abord un mot sur le
bilan de l'épidémie coronavirus dans
l'hexagone un peu plus de 28000 décès à
ce jour selon les chiffres de la
direction générale de la santé se soit
on dénombre 100 lits morts de plus lors
des 24 dernières heures le nombre de
personnes en réanimation continue de
baisser avec 100 personnes de moins
qu'hier et l'actualité
c'est le conseil des ministres
aujourd'hui bien évidemment
l'organisation des confidences et étape
au menu mais aussi le second tour des
élections municipales le conseil
scientifique a donné son accord pour le
mois de juin écoutez les précisions de
notre reporter sur place guillemin rossi
c'était le grand sujet du jour
l'organisation du second tour des
élections municipales à plus de trente
mille communes avaient d'ores et déjà
trouvé leur conseil municipal
au lendemain du 15 mars mais il en reste
près de 5000 4816 très exactement pour
lesquels un second tour est nécessaire
cela revient à envoyer 25 millions
d'électeurs environ aux urnes du côté du
gouvernement on privilégie la date du 28
juin
c'est aussi l'avis de plusieurs maires
de plusieurs grandes villes de france
comme christian estrosi à nice anne
hidalgo à paris ou encore nicolas
florian à bordeaux du côté du conseil
scientifique ont validé cette date du 28
juin en rappelant que la situation
sanitaire s'était nettement améliorée
par rapport aux débuts du confinement
mais voilà il cette échéance électorale
elle divise y compris au sein de la
majorité le président de l'assemblée
nationale
richard ferrand par exemple a émis des
réserves quant à la tenue de ce second
tour en juin qu'ils jugent déraisonnable
même son de cloche du côté de la chambre
haute avec le sénateur françois patriat
qui lui plaide carrément pour une
nouvelle élection en 2021 alors edouard
philippe a convié à matignon ici les
chefs de partis pour décider de la
meilleure date pour la tenue de ce
second tour
cela lui permet également de partager
les responsabilités en cas de nouvelle
crise
une terre où démocratique pour revenir
sur les derniers développements de la
journée nous sommes avec ludovic de
l'aer expert en communication bonsoir
ludovic de la recherche
merci d'être avec nous en direct sur rt
france avant les chefs de partis réunis
ce soir pour décider a de la tenue d'un
second tour
on voit évidemment et on comprend la
volonté de dialogue du gouvernement
c'est un choix politique avant tout
c'est un choix politique qui fait un
choix aussi de de communication me
semble-t-il stéphanie est ce que mon
soir d'abord merci de deux invités on
est dans un procès c'est une ritournelle
aujourd'hui qui est acté de la part de
notre chef de l'état emmanuel macron qui
souhaitent se déresponsabiliser on a
plusieurs sorties de sa part où il
affirme ce soit des fausses vérités
soient carrément des mensonges ou se
positionne en spectateur remettant tout
ça sans gouvernement
et là il tenterait en plus de tout
remettre sur les parlementaires qu'ils
devraient voter oui ou non pour ce
second tour
sans information et sans respect de deux
critères qui semble absolument essentiel
tout d'abord le premier qui est évident
qu'ils et sanitaires pour ne pas
reproduire les graves erreurs qu'ils ont
commis en organisant le premier tour il
faut oublier que ce premier tour a été
décidé seul par emmanuel macron et et
son gouvernement sans en demander au
préalable l'avis du parlement
et on connaît les conséquences et ses
conséquences et ses responsabilités
aujourd'hui ils essayent de le partager
et de demander au parlement de
l'endosser ce qui est évidemment
extrêmement compliqué parce que en plus
mécaniquement en termes de communication
ça permettrait de leur faire endosser
aussi le premier tour car après tout
s'ils votent pour un second tour
on pourrait suspecter qu'ils auraient
voté aussi pour un premier tour et ce
bilan du premier tour il est quand même
catastrophique donc il faut mais aussi
des mots sur les sur les choses parce
que on a eu beaucoup d'informations et
de fausses vérités qu'on circule et le
premier tour par exemple esmery hallon
dans les hauts de france
c'est cyril boulanger 37 ans qui est
mort le 5 avril l'udc au vide après
avoir voté et être assesseurs et c'est
aussi christophe batteur vasseur pardon
51 ans premier adjoint qui est mort le
28 avril voilà ça ce sont des noms
concrets et des faits concrets sur la
responsabilité du premier tour est ce
qu'on doit reproduire la même chose pour
le mieux pour le second tour
il tente de se déresponsabiliser à
nouveau comme il le fait sur l'ensemble
des éléments de cette crise qu vite
depuis le départ on a lu ici ou là
plusieurs fois injustement que le
gouvernement n'avait pas pris seul cette
responsabilité qu'ont contraire emmanuel
macron n'était pas spécialement chaud
pour organiser ce premier tour mais
qu'il a fait sous la pression notamment
de l'opposition vous n'y croyez pas ah
voilà ce postulat combi un petit peu
partout depuis ce premier tour quand
même sessegnon pour le moment autant de
communication emmanuel macron chaque
fois qu'il a pu imputer la
responsabilité clairement à quelqu'un il
l'a fait là ça a été dit à demi-mot
c'était effectivement écrit en disant
que ça aurait pu être éventuellement
externe terrain en attendant on est en
crise il a voulu les pleins pouvoirs et
c'est le chef de l'état donc c'est lui
qui décide soyons clairs il n'a pas
consulté le parlement il n'a pas
consulté officiellement l'opposition
c'est là qu'il n'y a pas eu de séance au
parlement pour le premier tour et là ils
veulent en faire une sur le second tour
on peut comprendre les réticences parce
que il faut deux points et le premier et
sanitaires comme je vous disais mais le
deuxième il est aussi démocratique parce
que pourquoi organiser un second tour
il faut absolument garantir un temps de
campagne une campagne et une élection
c'est un moment pour convaincre
c'est un moment pour un débat d'idées
pour exposer des projets et et
convaincre sur la pertinence de ces
projets il ne faut pas croire à cette
mécanique en marche qui croient que une
élection ça n'est qu'un exercice
comptable est bien dans la démocratie ça
n'est pas ça donc il faut pouvoir
garantir ces deux points là et
aujourd'hui on a un conseil scientifique
qui n'a pas avalisé qui n'a pas donné
son accord à à ceux à la tenue de ce
second tour
il n'a pas non plus c'est pas pu non
plus prononcée contre il a fait une
réponse un peu sibylline est évasive
donc donc il faut que emmanuel macron
s'ils souhaitent un deuxième tour prenne
ses responsabilités et l'imposent ou
alors en conscience le décalé vêtements
signés soit à la rentrée soit en 2021
aujourd'hui on le voit le gouvernement
et notamment le chef de l'état sont en
grande difficulté à quoi doit-on
s'apprend s'attendre on a parlé à un
temps du remplacement du premier
ministre
marine le pen elle demande la
dissolution de l'assemblée quelles sont
les alternatives les plus crédibles
selon vous ce qui est évident c'est ce
qui se dit et je vais pas dévoiler un
secret de polichinelle est ce qu'il
travaille à un gouvernement d'union
nationale nationale c'est à dire que sur
cette toujours cette séquence politique
de déresponsabilisation
il semblerait qu emmanuel macron
voudrait s'acheter une virginité avec un
gouvernement c'est-à-dire que emmanuel
philippe partirait avec l'eau du bain
on lui mettrait entre guillemets un tout
sur le dos pardonnez moi ces mots mais
c'est c'est la séquence sur lesquels on
est en train de se préparer pour réunir
un gouvernement qui serait autour de lui
grand chef vainqueur seul capable de
rassembler il décale déjà certains
députés pour ce reverdir estero
socialiser un peu donc il serait il sert
peint de rose rouge et de vert grâce à
ce nouveau mouvement au sein de
l'assemblée qui n'est pas un mouvement
de contestation vous ne faut pas non
plus nous prendre pour des idiots
et puis surtout en contre en continuant
de maintenir le parlement dans un rôle
qui n'est pas celui du parlement quitte
à consulter parlement il aurait fallu
les écouter plutôt le parlement il ya
quand même des gens qui travaillent
il y a un plan de déconfinement qui a
été proposé il a été repoussé de la main
et se confrontent en permanence à un
visage glacée de l'exécutif qui reste
dans sa propre litani et c'est encore
une fois une vision idéologique de la
politique le parlement n'est pas une
chambre comptable des bras levés en
cadence non ça n'est pas ça la
démocratie ça n'est pas ça le parlement
donc il en train de se préparer à un
gouvernement d'union et on peut très
bien imaginer oui derrière que fort de
ce gouvernement d'union il pourrait
avoir comme velléités de dissoudre
bon ça nous donnerait un élément concret
c'est qu'on aurait un chef de l'état
totalement hors sol étant donné
aujourd'hui
la cote de popularité du mouvement en
marche au sein de la population
française et des citoyens qui voient ce
qui se passe et qui entendent depuis le
départ et encore une fois prendre des
décisions il faut pouvoir le faire avec
des informations fiables et depuis le
début de cette crise s'il ya bien un
marqueur clair c'est que les fausses
vérités ont circulé sait qu'on a un
exécutif qui nous a menti cacher des
choses
très rapidement vous savez on a connu
aujourd'hui on a des informations
concrètes qui tombe le 28 février entre
le 28 février et le 6 mars le taux de
contamination en france a progressé de
5000 pour sans doute 5000% c'est
absolument énorme
c'est le ciment ou pardonnez moi je me
coupe mais c'est vrai qu'à d'autres
invités derrière et merci en tout cas on
a compris en substance votre analyse
ludovic de l'air pardonnez moi de vous
avoir coupé merci à vous d'avoir été
avec nous et face à l'éventuelle
fermeture de plusieurs usines renault en
france le gouvernement saura je cite
intransigeant sur leur préservation
en effet le constructeur automobile
envisage de fermer quatre sites sedan le
canard enchaîné ont fait le point avec
clémence pital sur la situation
un fleuron de l'histoire industrielle de
l'histoire économique et de l'histoire
sociale de la france
edouard philippe n'a pas ménagé ses
effets d'heure de la séance de questions
au gouvernement le premier ministre est
déterminé à préserver les sites de
renault en france
nous serons extrêmement attachés
intransigeant même je dirais à la
préservation du site france décident
france renault est une entreprise
mondiale c'est vrai mais enfin ça marque
française est évidente et donc nous
serons extrêmement exigeant sur ce point
nous serons extrêmement exigeants sur le
fait que la france demeure le centre
mondial pour renault de l'ingénierie de
la recherche de l'innovation du
développement
c'est quelque chose dont vous savez
d'ailleurs dans le département des
yvelines
c'est combien ces précieux pour préparer
l'avenir et pour garder une capacité à
préparer l'avenir le constructeur
automobile français envisage de fermer
quatre de ses sites
parmi eux flins dieppe choisy le roi ou
encore les fonderie de bretagne
selon le canard enchaîné le constructeur
automobile compte s'en séparer dans le
cadre d'un plan de 2 milliards d'euros
d'économies qui doit être dévoilé le 29
mai un groupe dont l'état est le premier
actionnaire
une intervention du gouvernement est
donc particulièrement attendu après
avoir beaucoup parlé de souveraineté
emmanuel macron va devoir passer aux
actes le projet de délocalisation
s'accélère l'inquiétude grandit comment
croire que le gouvernement qui pourtant
clame souveraineté airs et industrie
réalisation va intervenir alors que
macron vient de céder alstom alcatel
technip lafarge un futur incertain
critiquée également par philippe
martinez le patron de la cgt conteste la
stratégie du groupe automobile
mené ces dernières années quand on veut
réindustrialiser le pays
c'est impensable la situation de renault
n'est pas dû à la crise sanitaire
elle est due à des années de gouvernance
de carlos ghosn qui a été érigée comme
un dieu pendant des années et on voit
les conséquences de sa stratégie
c'est cette stratégie qu'il faut changer
est-ce que les 5 milliards que le
gouvernement s'apprête à prêter à
renault vont servir à restructurer
l'entreprise
c'est un gros problème la survie de
renault est un véritable enjeu pour
bercy ces fermetures et ses
restructurations pour y entraîner une
vague de licenciements et pour en parler
nous ça nous avec benjamin que
journaliste auteur le livre noir de
renault aux éditions first
bonsoir benjamin cucq merci d'être avec
nous en direct sur rt france alors du
parti communiste warren en passant par
l'est républicain les oppositions
demandé aujourd'hui à l'état de se faire
respecter
si renault devait confirmer ces
fermeture de quatre sites en france
c'est pas à l'ordre du jour pour le
moment condamnation unanime votre
réaction à vous c'est une condamnation
de gens qui ont été au pouvoir pendant
des années et qui ont organisé eux-mêmes
des délocalisations et c'est assez
amusant d'entendre le parti communiste
français qui est donc avec ses amis de
la cgt qui a une seule yens semaine a
refusé à faire en sorte de ne pas
reprendre le travail à sandouville
je veux à un moment il faut comme ça on
peut s'inquiéter de la
désindustrialisation par le manque de
volonté politique de certains politiques
de gauche comme de droite et de la
destruction de l'industrie automobile
par cette non volonté politique
maintenant je pousse des cris d'orfraie
alors que ce n'est que la consultation
de l'heure de leur politique est elle
pour vous il ya une forme d'hypocrisie
aujourd'hui dans ses réactions cc c'est
plus que d'hypocrisie ainsi quasiment de
la tartufferie quand on sait
quand on sait que certains politiques
certains partis politiques ont été au
pouvoir pendant quelques dizaines
d'années ont nommé des gens à la tête de
renault
des gens qui bossait à l'elysée par
exemple on derrière on se peut
s'interroger sur la réalité de la
politique du ps oui par exemple ou même
de la délocalisation des lamas garde
madame lagarde était ministre de
l'économie
quant aux renault était à délocaliser la
toux la clio en turquie
le ps était au pouvoir quand on renoue
avec rme délocaliser la twingo en
slovénie
on peut s'interroger sur les
conséquences de ces gens ces gens sont
des ces gens ces personnes politiques
ont des actions inconséquente et
viennent se plaindre des années après
alors et de renchérir le gouvernement
sera intransigeant sur la préservation
des sites en france
c'était de voir philippins qui le dit
aujourd'hui quelle est votre réaction
justement face à ce cette fermeté
affichée
bah je souhaite que le premier ministre
soit différent de ses prédécesseurs ne
serait ce que pour les l'intérêt
industriel de la france
il en va il aurait de l'intérêt logiciel
de la france on a vu il ya peu de temps
la semaine dernière les effets de sanofi
qui annonce que le vaccin serait
disponible à bord pour les américains
les français sanofi s'est d'abord à
thouars pharmaceutique français serait
dommage que renault ne soit plus une
entreprise française demain et donc
c'est à l'état aussi d'être protecteur
si le s'il veut être s'il veut montrer
qu'il est qu'il est fort et qu'il est et
maintenir l'emploi en france en tant
qu'actionnaire mais l'emploi de tout de
tout temps le gouvernement français
c'est qu'on sait qu'on portait en en
fonds de pension c'est à dire qu'il a
attendu des dividendes de renault il a
attendu des dividendes de renault et ils
cherchent encore une fois maintenir les
évidents puisque cette année pour la
première fois renault était déficitaire
depuis bien longtemps
alors le gouvernement en tout cas
prévoit les noms sous quinze jours
indique-t-il d'un plan de
soutien à l'automobile c'est de nature à
vous rassurer
oui c'est moi sûr mais c'est ça profite
à tous les constructeurs heureusement
nez on vit dans un an dans un pays libre
de marché et c'est là que le mail que le
meilleur gagne
moi j'ai eu des renault pendant des
années j'aime beaucoup cette marque si
renault m'offre nous propose fait une
offre commerciale intéressante
jésus dira avec je vois l'intérêt mais
je verrai aussi en fonction de lieu de
production c'est bien vers l'est c'est
sympa c'est sympa de faire est d'acheter
des voitures fabriquées à l'autre bout
du monde
mais si c'est fabriqué c'est fabriqué
par des employés la bague sont des
chômeurs en france et par des chômeurs
en france sont merci pour défendre son
industrie en fait une forme de
patrimoine et de patriotisme
patrimoniale et industriels
moi je suis et je suis et je suis
libéral je suis là d'essence libérale
alors justement c'est c'est un mot le
patriotisme en ce moment après cette
crise du duc hobby de 19 ans parle de de
rockwell relocaliser les industries en
france ça concerne certainement
l'automobile aussi un vous y croyez ou
c'est pas gagné quand même un bain le
problème c'est qu'il ya un coût du
travail en france qui est très élevé si
vous produisez en france vous
renchérissait de 10% si vous produisez
toutes les renault en france a renchéri
c'est 10% le prix d'une renault elle
devient plus compétitif par rapport au
reste c'est à dire qu'elle tourne au
kivu nouveau sur 1 sur un an et dix ans
la renault sera 110 donc le marché fera
qu'on ira plutôt sur une autre voiture
et en même temps on peut acheter une
toyota qui fabrique et en france on fore
des usines en france des usines de
moteurs et des usines qui emploient des
frontaliers à sarrelouis en à sarrebruck
en allemagne bond à sare on peut il ya
d'autres constructeurs
on peut on peut fabriquer des voitures
étrangères en france ce n'est pas un
problème et on peut fabriquer des
voitures françaises dans l'union
européenne c'est pas un problème faut
simplement pas totalement vide et c'est
le jure f2c de cbc
politiciens qui rêvaient d'une entrevue
d'une france sans usines
c'est un vieux rêve de l'est de l'ère
mitterrand ça c'est la france sans
usines
il faudrait une france qui n'a plus du
sinn voilà moi je suis pas miterrandiste
donc ça me pose le problème de penser
que c'est bien qu'ils aient des usines
en france
merci beaucoup et benjamin accuse
d'avoir été avec nous en direct sur rtl
france journalistes auteurs du livre
noir de renault merci à vous le nombre
de déclarations d'embauché de plus d'un
mois dans le secteur privé hors intérim
a chuté de plus de 64% au mois d'avril
un plongeon sans précédent alors que
l'économie française était quasiment à
l'arrêt sous l'effet du confinement
décrété mi mars pour ralentir la
propagation du nouveau corps navires us
reculé 2 73 8% sur trois mois et de 73 %
sur un an selon la caisse nationale des
urssaf l'arrêt de l'économie et les
mesures de report du règlement les
échéances sociales ont par ailleurs
porté le ton d'un payer les cotisations
hors taxes à sion dauphine issa plus de
30 4% fin avril
et pour en parler nous sommes avec alain
trannoy économistes bonsoir à l'a13 d'un
à merci d'être avec nous en direct sur
rt france que traduisent ces chiffres
annoncés par l' agence centrale des
organismes de sécurité sociale selon
vous bonsoir
ces chiffres sont tout sauf surprenant
les français étaient pour la une par une
part importante d'entre eux ne pouvaient
pas aller produire et il pouvait pas
aller consommer donc les pas étonnant
dans ces conditions que les embauches
étaient soit revenu disons à la plus
simple expression
c'est tout à fait dans l'ordre des
choses maintenant la question qui se
pose c'est de savoir si ce mouvement va
s'arrêter ou est-ce qu'il va y avoir une
reprise progressive des embauches dans
les mois à venir
alors justement c'était ma question
suivante effectivement l'activité
économique a repris véritablement et
encore
pas totalement le 11 mai selon vous
peut-on s'attendre à un meilleur bilan
dans les mois qui arrivent quel est
votre pronostic même si j'imagine vous
n'avez pas de boule de cristal mais je
pense que le mois d'avril représente un
point bas et qu'on va assister dans les
mois à venir et d'abord pour le mois de
mai je dirais à des chiffres moins
mauvais mais on sera pas du tout encore
motivation de retour à la normale et il
faut s'attendre à ce que le chômage en
france soit ils ont beaucoup plus haut
cette année en 2020 et encore sans doute
également 2021
ce n'est peut-être qu'en 2022 qu'on
retrouvera le niveau d'activité qu'on
avait en 2019
donc c'est une situation totalement
inédite qui n'a pas d'équivalent depuis
la seconde guerre mondiale avec je
dirais une baisse d'activité économique
le gouvernement prévoit 8 % ça peut
facilement aller à 10 % 10 % de baisse
il faut remonter disons la seconde
guerre mondiale pour avoir un une
faiblesse aussi important de l'activité
économique
donc je dirais que pour les deux
prochaines années
faut attendre à une situation du marché
de l'emploi dégradée et donc il faut
donc accompagner en terme de retour à
l'emploi en termes de subvention à la
création d'entreprise
les subventions à à la création
d'emplois al embauche au monde en 2010
2008 moment du 10 honda présidence de
nicolas sarkozy au moment de la grande
crise financière
il y a eu je dirais des subventions à
l'embauché qui ont été un plan de
subventions à gauche qui a été élaboré
et deux économies sont étudiés à fond
qu'elle a été l'efficacité de ce plan
de subventions allant bouche et ils ont
montré que ça avait permis l'embauché de
300 mille personnes donc je pense que
c'est peut-être encore un petit peu tôt
parce que évidemment il faut que la
situation sioniste sanitaires soient
assainis mais on peut penser qu'à partir
de septembre
ça serait bien qu'il y est je dirais en
même temps que dirait dbz qui restent
importantes en termes de de maintien à
l'emploi des travailleurs existent en
particulier les cdi mais pourrait
encourager l'embauché des cdd pourrait
encourager l'embauché des jeunes parce
que je rappelle qu'au mois de septembre
c'est toute une nouvelle génération de
jeunes diplômés qui va venir sur marché
du travail il est donc indispensable
d'accompagner cette arrivée par des
conditions financières beaucoup plus
favorable pour les entreprises de
permettent de façon à permettre quand
même une embauche de cette nouvelle
génération et et faire en sorte qu'elles
soient pas sacrifiées sur marché du
travail merci à vous alain trannoy nous
avoir apporté votre analyse en direct
sur rt français avant de refermer cette
émission cette information qui vient
tout juste de nous parvenir
vous le savez edouard philippe va
rencontrer ce soir les chefs de partis
pour évoquer la question du second tour
des municipales le conseil scientifique
avait donné son feu on va dire orange à
la tenue de ce second tour pour la fin
juin est bien le premier ministre à
l'instant a affirmé aux parties que le
second tour aurait lieu en juin ou en
janvier 2021
ce qui n'est pas tout à fait les mêmes
choses effectivement on développera
cette information notamment dans notre
prochain journal si on en sait un petit
peu plus d'ailleurs c'est pas sûr c'est
la fin de cette émission en tout cas on
se retrouve donc à 22 heures pour un
point complet sur l'actualité
[Musique]
vous parlez de résilience comment est-ce
qu'on pourrait le définir
c'est après un traumatisme qu'est ce
qu'on sait combien on reste traumatisée
bien on cherche en soi et autour de soi
quels sont les facteurs qui vont nous
permettre de reprendre un nouveau
développement est l'un fonds talents de
résilience la catastrophe économique
dont on parle
elle est liée directement au confinement
c'est à dire à la mise en coma
artificiel de l'économie catastrophe ça
veut dire à côté
cata strophe là il ya un tournant et on
refera met à vivre mais dans une autre
direction c'est la première fois dans
l'histoire de l'humanité que pour sauver
des vies humaines en ruines la moitié de
la planète
jamais on a fait ça jamais plaint d'une
décision à vraisemblable pour vous ça
dépend quelle valeur on attribuait la
mort la vie humaine
si on considère que la vie humaine est
plus précieuse que l'économie on a bien
fait mais si on considère que maintenant
il va y avoir des catastrophes humaines
individuelles avec cette décision
alors je sais pas le c'est un débat
n'aura un débat éthique
[Musique]
ici on écoute ceux qui ne sont pas
d'accord ici qu'on invite les plus
compétents pas seulement ceux qui
parlent le plus fort ici on reçoit c'est
qu'on ne voit pas ailleurs
[Musique]
parce qu'ici c'est interdit d'interdire
vous parlez de résilience comment est-ce
qu'on pourrait le définir
c'est après un traumatisme qu'est ce
qu'on sait combien on reste traumatisée
bien on cherche en soi et autour de soi
quels sont les facteurs qui vont
permettre de reprendre un nouveau
développement est l'un font 42
résilience la catastrophe économique
dont on parle
elle est liée directement au confinement
c'est à dire à la mise en coma
artificiel de l'économie catastrophe ça
veut dire à côté
gata ce trop fine il ya un tournant mais
on re se remet à vivre mais dans une
autre direction c'est la première fois
dans l'histoire de l'humanité que pour
sauver des vies humaines en ruines
la moitié de la planète jamais on a fait
ça jamais une décision après semblable
pour vous ça dépend quelle valeur on
attribue à la mort et à la vie humaine
si on considère que la vie humaine est
plus précieuse que l'économie revient
feu mais si on considère que maintenant
il va y avoir des catastrophes humaines
individuelles avec cette décision
alors je sais pas le c'est un débat
moral un débat éthique
c'est chacun pour soi dieu pour tous
petit coup politique n'a jamais été
obligé de dire la vérité d idée
courageuse des mots qui comptent en soi
vient des lignes en france aujourd'hui
on a une gauche extrêmement
tous les témoins de notre époque sont
dans la grande idée review nous allons
évoquer ici les sujets stratégiques pour
notre pays et sur ces dossiers sensibles
je vais partager avec vous une
interprétation la croissance des pays
émergents
la stagnation des pays occidentaux et le
ralentissement de ceux en développement
ont rendu la compétition économique
internationale
brut 1 soyons clairs dans la guerre
économique
tous les coups sont permis la stratégie
de conquête de marchés à l'exportation
s'appuie sur une politique offensive de
pillages deux fleurons du secteur
stratégique
le succès passe toujours par la
connaissance parfaite de son adversaire
en jouant sur quatre critères clés
l'argent l'idéologie légaux et la
compromission
ce phénomène il est mondial on le
retrouve partout
c'est pourquoi on est frappé par la
naïveté des personnels et d'encadrement
race ce qui prime
il n'existe sur la planète beaucoup
d'acteurs chez qui est sans aucune
hésitation ni morale
la fin justifie les moyens
[Musique]
tous
[Applaudissements]
dans ce contexte de crise sanitaire
mondiale quel rôle doivent selon vos
jouets à lévis lesquels rôle joue-t-elle
dans les faits les villes tout comme les
états ils étaient pas préparés
c'est là mais les villes elles se sont
connectés tout de suite entre elles pour
voir comment elles pouvaient coopérer
il ya eu l'envoi des beaucoup de des
masques des matériels médicaux d'une
commune à l'autre selon vous à quoi
pourront ressembler les îles comment
est-ce qu'elles vont se transformer
après la pandémie la crise maintenant à
fait bien comprendre qu'on paie pas
s'oublier des banlieues on peut pas
oublier les quartiers pauvres parce que
véritablement être en partie de la vie
donc les grandes villes quand il se
connecte n est pas pas seulement d'elle
même elle parle aussi de comment créer
un cercle vertueux avec les villes des
alentours
[Musique]
le second tour des municipales aura lieu
en juin ou janvier 2021 déclaration
d'edouard philippe à l'issue de la
réunion avec les chefs de parti des
différents partis politiques ce soir et
hier le conseil scientifique a donné un
prudent en feu vert le ministre de la
santé lui s'est engagé pour un renouveau
hôpital public 1 en europe la suède a
suivi sa propre stratégie celle du nom
confinement et de l'immunité collective
si les autres pays il est peu à peu les
mesures de restriction les suédois
envisage eux de les maintenir plus
longtemps
côté italien les aéroports pour en
rouvrir à partir du 3 juin
antic le canada se prépare à retrouver
une liberté de circulation ce lundi 25
mai mais l'inquiétude demeure car la
belle province concentre plus de 2200
décès c'était le 13 avril dernier
emmanuel macron parle d' annuler
massivement les dettes des pays
africains lors d'un débat en ligne
organisé hier cinq présidents africains
ont plaidé aussi pour cette annulation
même si le continent semblent quelque
peu épargnée faso commis 19 les
dirigeants évoquent une priorité pour
l'économie
[Musique]
et
bonsoir à tous bienvenue si nous
rejoignent et en direct sur rt france le
second tour des municipales aura lieu en
juin ou janvier 2021 déclaration
d'edouard philippe à l'issue de la
réunion avec les chefs des différents
partis politiques
un conseil des ministres s'est tenue ce
matin au programme l'organisation du
déconfinement bien sûr justement ce
second tour des élections municipales le
conseil scientifique avait donné son
accord pour le mois de juin conditions
leur évaluer la situation quinze jours
avant pour joaquim pueyo député ps de la
première circonscription de l'or en est
candidat à la mairie des lançant si le
déconfinement se passe bien il n'y aura
pas d'inconvénient à la tenue de ce
second tour le mois prochain
nous sommes d'accord pour dire au
premier ministre
ok pour le 28 juin sous réserve bien
évidemment que les conditions sanitaires
soient réunies et que quinze jours avant
le comité scientifique donne à nouveau
son feu vert
et dans ces conditions il n'y a aucune
raison pour que les élections n'aient
pas lieu dans la mesure où on demande
aux français de travailler on a ouvert
les écoles les collèges
on va peut-être ouvrir les lieux de
restauration des lieux touristiques
courant juin donc on peut effectivement
ouvrir dans ces conditions les bureaux
de vote si on peut pas ça veut dire
qu'effectivement le déconfinement aurait
échoué tant qu'on n'a pas de base de
vaccins il faudra vivre avec le co vide
et on sait pas où on en sera au mois de
septembre ou à l'automne parce que si on
repasse en septembre en octobre
est ce qu'on sera débarrassés du coc
vite je ne suis pas certain donc si le
déconfinement se passe plutôt bien
s'il n'y a pas de deuxième vague si les
conditions sanitaires sont respectées je
pense que on peut aller voter comme on
peut aller effectivement dans d'autres
lieux qui seront ouvert courant juin
voici le bilan d'épidémie coronavirus
dans l'hexagone on compte un peu plus de
28000 décès selon les chiffres de la
direction générale de la santé
elles sont dix morts de plus sont
comptabilisés lors des 24 dernières
heures le nombre de personnes en
réanimation continue 8
et c'est avec 100 personnes de moins
qu'hier face à l'éventuelle fermeture de
plusieurs usines renault en france le
gouvernement sera je cite intransigeant
sur leur préservation en effet le
constructeur automobile envisage de
fermer quatre sites en fait le point
avec les mains spital sur la situation
un fleuron de l'histoire industrielle de
l'histoire économique et de l'histoire
sociale de la france
edouard philippe n'a pas ménagé ses
effets lors de la séance de questions au
gouvernement le premier ministre est
déterminé à préserver les sites de
renault en france
nous serons extrêmement attachés
intransigeant même je dirais à la
préservation du site france décident
france
renault est une entreprise mondiale
c'est vrai mais enfin ça marque
française est évidente et donc nous
serons extrêmement exigeant sur ce point
nous serons extrêmement exigeants sur le
fait que la france demeure le centre
mondial pour renault de l'ingénierie de
la recherche de l'innovation du
développement
c'est quelque chose dont vous savez
d'ailleurs dans le département des
yvelines sait combien ces précieux pour
préparer l'avenir et pour garder une
capacité à préparer l'avenir
le constructeur automobile français
envisage de fermer quatre de ses sites
parmi eux flins dieppe choisy le roi ou
encore les fonderie de bretagne
selon le canard enchaîné le constructeur
automobile compte s'en séparer dans le
cadre d'un plan de 2 milliards d'euros
d'économies qui doit être dévoilé le 29
mai un groupe dont l'état est le premier
actionnaire
une intervention du gouvernement est
donc particulièrement attendu après
avoir beaucoup parlé de souveraineté
emmanuel macron va devoir passer aux
actes le projet de délocalisation
s'accélère l'inquiétude grandit comment
croire que le gouvernement qui pourtant
clame souveraineté et
réindustrialisation va intervenir alors
que macro vient de céder alstom alcatel
technip lafarge un futur incertain
critiquée également par philippe
martinez le patron de la cgt conteste la
stratégie du groupe automobile
mené ces dernières années quand on veut
industrialiser le pays c'est impensable
la situation de renault n'est pas dû à
la crise sanitaire
elle est due à des années de gouvernance
de carlos ghosn qui a été érigée comme
un dieu pendant des années et on voit
les conséquences de sa stratégie
c'est cette stratégie qu'il faut changer
est ce que les 5 milliards que le
gouvernement s'apprête à prêter à
renault vont servir à restructurer
l'entreprise
c'est un gros problème la survie de
renault est un véritable enjeu pour
bercy ces fermetures et ses
restructurations pour y entraîner une
vague de licenciements est la france
perd son industrie par manque de volonté
politique c'est la vie de benjamin
qu'une journaliste auteur du livre noir
de renault éditions first
à un moment il faut comme ça on peut
s'inquiéter de la désindustrialisation
par le manque de volonté politique de
certains politiques de gauche comme de
droite et de la destruction de
l'industrie automobile par cette non
volonté politique
quand on sait que certains politiques
certains partis politiques ont été au
pouvoir pendant quelques dizaines
d'années ont nommé des gens à la tête de
renault
des gens qui bossait à l'elysée par
exemple on derrière on se peut
s'interroger sur la réalité de la
politique du ps oui par exemple ou même
dans la délocalisation de la gare de
madame lagarde était ministre de
l'économie
quand renault était à délocaliser la
toux la clio en turquie
le ps était au pouvoir quand renault a
déclaré mme délocaliser la twingo en
slovénie
on peut s'interroger sur les
conséquences de ces gens ces gens sont
des ces gens ces personnels politiques
ont des actions inconséquente et
viennent s'en plaindre des années après
de tout temps le gouvernement français
c'est qu'on s'est comporté en en fonds
de pension c'est à dire qu'il a attendu
des dividendes de renault il a attendu
des dividendes de renault et ils
cherchent encore une fois maintenir les
dividendes puisque cette année pour la
première fois renault était déficitaire
depuis bien longtemps
en europe un pays qui fait cavalier seul
la suède elle n'a jamais confiné sa
population sol des recommandations
étaient donnés les chiffres eux sont là
3700 décès liés aux convives 19 un bilan
bien supérieur à celui de ses voisins
scandinaves mais le gouvernement suédois
le martèle il s'agit d'une stratégie à
long terme
walid bennani contrairement aux autres
grandes capitales européennes les rues
de stockholm n'ont jamais étaient
désertes ces deux derniers mois
allez à la pandémie qui touche la
majorité des pays du monde y compris le
leur les suédois semble presque épargnée
par cette situation inédite
de son côté le gouvernement ne cesse de
rappeler dans ses discours
sa ligne directrice cette lutte contre
le coc u19 est un marathon et les
mesures prises ont donc été choisis
parce que nous croyons fermement
qu'elles sont viables à long terme
la vie ne se déroule pas normalement en
suède et pourtant pas de confinement les
bars les restaurants les commerces sont
restés ouverts tout comme les écoles
primaires et les collèges
face à la crise sanitaire les autorités
ont misé sur le bon sens et la
solidarité nationale les règles de
distanciation sociales sont conseillés
pas de masque obligatoire le travail à
domicile et encourager les personnes
âgées de plus de 70 ans sont incités à
s'isoler
seuls les rassemblements de plus de 50
personnes et les visites en maison de
retraite sont interdits je pense que la
stratégie suédoise s'est avéré durable
je veux dire que nous obtenions des
chiffres maintenant que les gens
adhèrent de plus en plus à nos conseils
il est apparemment assez facile de
commencer un confinement
mais l'arrêté est beaucoup plus
difficile de convaincre la population
qu'un jour vous êtes censé faire ceci et
le lendemain vous êtes censé faire autre
chose et je pense que cela revient à la
question de la durabilité la durabilité
est très importante lorsque vous
travaillez avec la santé publique et les
maladies transmissibles
qu'on peut anticiper une deuxième vague
la stratégie de la suède repose sur
l'idée que le virus ne va pas
disparaître de sitôt et qu'il doit
circuler lentement au sein de la société
pour ne pas engorger les services
hospitaliers avec 1100 lits disponibles
la capacité d'accueil a été doublé dans
les unités de réanimation le système de
santé suédois se prépare à une situation
qui pourrait durer plusieurs mois
nous prévoyons de travailler ainsi
pendant tout l'été et nous devrons
ensuite continuer à analyser l'évolution
de la pandémie et nous le faisons chaque
jour chaque semaine pour voir où nous
allons si le nombre de malades augmente
si nous avons plus de patients et nous
continuerons à le faire aussi longtemps
que nécessaire probablement toute
l'année une sérénité symbolisée par la
cote de popularité en hausse du
gouvernement selon l'institut de sondage
nos bus 63 % des suédois sont satisfaits
de l'actuelle gestion de la crise
sanitaire avec un bond de 20% en un mois
fin avril le responsable des programmes
d'urgence de l' oms déclaré que la suède
pourrait servir de futurs modèles en
matière de lutte contre le coc vie de
19,1 porto malinbaum journaliste et
historien la stratégie du gouvernement
était la plus adaptée à la population
suédoise
on voit que le nombre de décès est quand
même en seo et sap est très inquiétant
en même temps on voit aussi que comme le
premier ministre dit il faut voir ça de
nong terme
qu'est ce qui va être le résultat dans
un nom ça c'est un deuxième réflexion je
voudrais aussi dire une troisième
infection c'est que est ce que ça aurait
été possible en suède de faire autrement
que d'avoir cette politique cette
stratégie qu'on a fait parce que chaque
pays n'est pas on peut pas comparer le
pays facilement il ya des différences
culturelles et historiques entre chaque
pays
on a parlé des grandes crises
catastrophe comme dans beaucoup d'autres
pays en europe
donc on a un peu l'idée que être
renfermé confiné elle comme dans
d'autres pays
ça serait très difficile les gens beaux
probablement pas accepter ça de la même
façon
au canada l'épidémie de kobe 19 continue
d'inquiéter plus particulièrement dans
la province francophone du québec la
ville de montréal est aujourd'hui l'une
des dix villes du monde où le virus
était le plus de morts par habitant
depuis lundi plusieurs barrages
permettant aux forces de l'ordre de
contrôler les allées et venues entre les
provinces ont été levées une situation
qui inquiète de plus en plus les voisins
du québec le président et directeur
général de l'alliance de l'industrie
touristique du québec tente de rassurer
il ne faut pas stigmatiser montréal
parce que cela représente 40 à 60% du
marché touristique pour les régions mais
il faut comprendre l'inquiétude est là
qu elle met progressivement travaille en
partenariat avec les municipalités le
ministère du tourisme a les chambres de
commerce locales sachant que le tourisme
un apport économique important dans
chacune des régions
alors comment expliquer que le québec
soit plus touchés que les autres
provinces du pays écouter l'analyse de
jérôme blanchet gravel correspondant de
scouts n'est qu'au canada le québec
c'est 22 pour cent de la population
canadienne mais c'est plus de 50 % des
cas dans l'ensemble la fédération
d'avoir le québec compte de très très
nombreuses personnes âgées ont le vu le
système d'hébergement des aînés
complètement revoir série stoppée
une situation qui ressemble à celle de
la france donc les centres de personnes
âgées non autonomes ont été très
durement touchée donc le nombre élevé de
personnes âgées explique d'avoir pour
que montréal est aussi touché un
deuxième main la distanciation sociale
qui aurait été plus difficile à
appliquer dans certains quartiers dans
des quartiers peut-être un peu moins et
riche donc c'est la deuxième explication
troisième explication peut-être une plus
grande réticence des canadiens français
des québécois appliquée
les mesures de confinement peut être les
restes d'un certain esprit latin qui
aurait fait en sorte que les gens c'est
ça était plus raide saint appliquer des
consignes que dans le canada anglais
ou peut-être que les gens ont une
culture peu plus puritaine plus proche
de certaines hygiénisme si je faisais où
la crise sanitaire de plus en plus
graves au daguestan république russe
située dans le sud du pays plus de 40
médecins sont décédés récemment des
suites d'une pneumonie après avoir
contracté le kobe 19 et l'information
révélée par le ministre de la santé
local
les précisions à moscou de notre
correspondant antoine claireaux oui les
autorités l'ont souligné à de nombreuses
reprises les différentes régions de
russie ne sont pas atteintes de la même
façon par cette pandémie
parmi les régions les plus touchées il y
a donc le daghestan cette république
russe située dans le nord du caucase où
de nombreux personnels de santé
ils sont morts de pneumonie ou des
suites du gorna virus d'après le
ministre de la santé de la région alors
plusieurs facteurs en sont la cause il
ya le manque de respect des règles de
confinement ou encore l'auto médication
et le recours trop tardif aux soins
médicaux et vladimir poutine s'en est
inquiété lors de sa dernière
visioconférence déguster cette escouade
les chiens ni proust elle la situation
daguestan est difficile de plus en plus
de cas d'infection et de complications
graves sont identifiés et ces derniers
jours le système de santé de la région a
été mise à rude épreuve
malgré les efforts des roues et des
médecins et des infirmiers le nombre de
tragédies a augmenté y compris au sein
du personnel soignant
en outre on dit que les soins médicaux
nécessaires ne sont pas toujours et
partout disponibles en temps voulu et
dans leur intégralité et l'atonie vie en
effet les infrastructures médicales sur
place ne sont pas celles de la capitale
même si la construction dans cette
région de trois nouveaux complexes
médicaux a été annoncée par exemple la
russie à cette approche on a déjà dit de
tester un maximum de monde plus de 7
millions de wii de tests ont déjà été
réalisées attaquer ce temps le nombre de
tests menés est deux fois moindre que
prévu
faute de laboratoire pour pouvoir
analyser les échantillons
en conséquence le personnel médical sur
place prêtent tous les patients de la
même manière qu'il s'agisse de cas
confirmés ou non en attendant reste donc
la prévention pour tenter d'enrayer la
propagation du virus
même la superstar de la mma rats bible
no mago madoff est monté au créneau pour
appeler ses compatriotes à respecter le
confinement dans le reste du pays
la lente décrue se confirme et pour la
première fois depuis le début de cette
crise il ya davantage de guérison
enregistré que deux nouveaux cas ces
dernières 24 heures mais comme on vient
de le voir la situation est loin d'être
homogène partout
ainsi le commis 19 semble en partie
épargné l'afrique les conséquences
économiques de la pandémie s'annonce
très grave pour le continent africain
il pourrait connaître une récession pour
la première fois en un quart de siècle
dans ce contexte cinq présidents
demandent l'annulation des dettes
africaines
[Musique]
[Rires]
- dans ce contexte de crise sanitaire
inédite et face à des conséquences
économiques qui s'annoncent très gras
faut-il annuler les dettes africaines
c'était l'objet de notre face à face
total à l'annulation serait un ballon
d'oxygène qu'on pourrait offrir à eau
aux états africains notamment en matière
budgétaire
quand on sait par exemple qu'un pays
comme le ghana l'aneth le remboursement
de sa dette annuelle ça représente cette
fois le budget de la santé
donc il faut il faut absolument parvenir
à trouver des voies pour redonner cette
puissance budgétaire aux pays africains
pour investir dans leur santé investir
dans les infrastructures sanitaires dans
leur éducation etc pour faire face aux
défis à venir celui de la crise du
coronavirus mais au delà défis de
l'éducation des filles de la culture le
défi de la sécurité le défi des
infrastructures donc
donc voila nous on plaide en tout cas
moi je fais partie mais parlementaire
qui plaident eux de manière très forte
pour qu'on en arrive à pas simplement
une un rééchelonnement ou alors une
transformation de cette dette non une
annulation pure et simple
bien entendu que je suis comme tout le
monde je suis d'accord que l'afrique
soit je soutenais soutenu par l'appel du
coq 19 ce qui me gêne pas rêver c'est la
méthode
aujourd'hui les applications elles
n'étaient pas visibles de la face mais
vous êtes de la chine
donc si elle demandait à faire il ne
faut surtout pas qu il faut aller vers
la chine est pour le moment j'attends
pas en fait nos chefs d'état africains
faire une démarche que dit bleu clair
vers les partenaires chinois et donc je
me dis est ce que tout ça le soliste par
une façon de enfin justifié la
récupération africaine donc voilà donc
bien entendu je suis pour l'anniversaire
de la dédicace africain mais la méthode
en tout cas 10 préconisée par le chef
d'état alassane ouattara comme macky
sall du sénégal et la méthode de cette
méthode homogène et le projet de loi
mettant fin au franc cfa été adopté
aujourd'hui en conseil des ministres
perçu comme un vestige de la
françafrique il devient désormais l'écho
le projet de loi adopté aujourd'hui
valide cette transformation
la réforme avait déjà amorcé était déjà
amorcée fin décembre entre manuel macro
et les gouvernements des états membres
de l'union monétaire ouest africaine
le franc cfa et est considéré comme un
signe de dépendance vis-à-vis de la
france par ses détracteurs
la porte parole du gouvernement a parlé
d'un texte très attendu le ministre de
l'europe et des affaires étrangères jean
yves le drian ainsi que le ministre de
l'économie et des finances bruno le
maire ont présenté un projet de loi qui
était très attendu très attendu par un
certain nombre de nos pays de nos
partenaires africains en particulier
ceux des pays de l'union monétaire
africaine c'était lors d'une visite
officielle en côte d'ivoire en décembre
dernier dont qu'ils avaient annoncé à
cette occasion une réforme historique de
la coopération monétaire qui devait
aboutir à la fin du franc cfa comme le
président la république avait pu le
souligner cette fin symbolique devait
s'inscrire dans une dans un
renouvellement de la relation entre la
france et les pays africains
1 direction le maroc ou le confinement a
été prolongée lundi jusqu'au 10 juin
mise en place depuis le 20 mars dernier
il devait prendre fin ce mercredi 20 mai
comment le confinement est il géré dans
le pays la réponse en images
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
com
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
e
mais pour abdelmalek alaoui président de
l'institut marocain d'intelligence
stratégique éditorialiste pour la
tribune d'afrique il est encore trop tôt
pour voir l'économie marocaine
redémarrer dans le discours politique et
dans le discours des pouvoirs publics
c'est un choix qui est clairement assumé
ce une situation qui n'est pas
différente de ce que beaucoup d'autres
pays ont entrepris en matière de mise
sous cloche de leurs économies le temps
que la pandémie soit soit soit maîtrisé
dans le cas du maroc de surcroît il ya
une connexion avec l'économie mondiale
avec le sud de l'europe et des
conditions ne sont pas réunies
aujourd'hui pour que l'économie puisse
redémarrer totalement est pleinement
mais il ya des indications et la presse
se fait l'écho du fait que certains
secteurs de l'économie devrait
redémarrer avant même que la levée du
confinement ne soit ordonnée par les
autorités compétentes pour l'instant il
n'y a pas d'indication claire vis de
communiqué de la part en prêt de la
branche de l'exécutif sur quand est ce
que les frontières sont ouvertes mais il
faut savoir que nous sommes également
dépendants de la réouverture de l'espace
schengen puisqu'une grande partie des
touristes y convergent vers notamment
les zones estivale du royaume arrive de
cette zone schengen et que pour
l'instant on ne voit pas encore la
réouverture de ses dents voilà les
remèdes contre le coc vie 19 parfois
originaux en attendant le vaccin
illustration en amazonie ou des
indigènes expérimente le traitement des
symptômes du commis 19 par les plantes
le récit est signée grégoire douce et
tirer partie de la nature pour se
soigner faire s'envoler les symptômes du
coronavirus par l'ingestion de plantes
médicinales
c'est la recette de certains indigènes
dans l'état de l'amazonas au brésil un
moyen d'être indépendant sur le plan
sanitaire
alors qu'un sentiment de délaissement
vis-à-vis des autorités brésiliennes
s'empare de plusieurs peuples
autochtones
une tendance qui s'est particulièrement
accentuée depuis l'arrivée de jaillir
vole sonar au pouvoir il semble qu'ils
choisissent qui s'occupe de nous et qui
nous laissent sans attention nous avons
appris à nous occuper de nous mêmes
nous avons appris à nous battre seule
première étape pour concocter la potion
magique à prendre des connaissances des
anciens je parle toujours à mon
grand-père marcos il à 93 ans et il en
sait beaucoup sur la médecine
je suis allé lui demander quoi faire
parce que je ne voulais pas utiliser les
médicaments donnés par l'homme blanc car
j'avais déjà entendu dire que ça ne
marche pas sur tous les patients vient
ensuite la récolte des ingrédients les
membres de la communauté satéré mawé
utilise par exemple cette écorce d'arbre
présente dans la forêt amazonienne
après avoir fait bouillir les plantes le
remède répartis en petites doses produit
des effets salvateurs selon les
autochtones
nous avons prêté tous les symptômes que
nous avons eues avec des remèdes maison
grâce aux connaissances transmises de
génération en génération
chaque membre a acquis une maîtrise des
remèdes nous avons fait des expériences
chaque remède combat un symptôme de la
maladie
le sirop fait maison a beaucoup aidé à
me soulagé parce que j'étais fatigué
c'était comme si on avait attrapé mes
poumons
j'étais essoufflé et j'ai pris du sirop
plus que jamais les communautés
amazoniennes compte sur les
connaissances ancestrales
le ministère brésilien de la santé
recense 371 contamination et 23 décès au
sein des indigènes du pays
des chiffres en dessous de la réalité
selon l'association des peuples
indigènes du brésil qui évoque 5 137 cas
confirmés et 102 morts c'est la fin de
cette édition merci de l'avoir suivi
prochain rendez-vous avec l'actualité
demain matin 7 heures du matin heure
française
[Musique]
on va parler évidemment de l'impact
économique de cette pandémie est ce que
tous les pays africains vont être
impactés continu envers voit vraiment
une de ses pires années de ses tantes
dernière même si les conséquences sont
différentes selon les pays
nous avons là une situation où pour
sauver les économies africaines il va
falloir créer de l'activité il faut de
l'argent pour pouvoir se tirer
d'affaires pendant cette année 73
millions de personnes touchées quand
même par les crises alimentaires dans
quelle mesure cette pandémie du colis de
19 risque d'aggraver les choses ça c'est
la troisième crise la part la sanitaire
et est là et la crise économique nous
allons avoir une crise de sécurité
alimentaire
on vit tous les jours sans faire